and am I good to start
now yes go right ahead right thank you
good morning everyone as chair of the
children and family law committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee an executive session may
follow please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
notice complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
27136 or EMA email
HCS l.st do. Us in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled Christina Dyer is the staff
assisting us please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also state where there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
clerk good morning Madam chair and CFL
committee me
Banger I am present in my home my wife
is in the other room um I'll be going in
office representative
Marsh good morning everyone I am present
in my home office in Brookfield New
Hampshire and I am currently
alone thank you representative D
Simon good morning I am in the L in room
representative
grman good morning everyone I'm in my
kitchen and I have two remote Learners
husband thank
alone representative
lucki I am in the LLB um with the uh
chairman and the vice
Lichfield representative long I'm in my
house
alone representative
patrio good morning I'm here alone in my
home
Smith I'm here um in the house with two
remote Learners and my
husband I'm sorry I'm here
husband representative
wazir yes I am here in my kitchen with
chairman representative
rice I'm in the lb room 210 and 211 with
my vice chair and representative liwicki
puppy thank you madam cler I see that
representative Al Schiller has um come
on
Shiller are you good morning I'm here in
stratum in my office and I am
alone thank you thank you madam chair
thank you very much all right so today
we are going to continue the public
um we will start the testimony with
Derek
champagne Mr CH if you could um State
who you are where you're from and who
you are
representing uh thank you madam chair uh
my name's Derek champagne um I am a
resident of Lancaster New Hampshire and
I am testifying on on behalf of the
ahead hello everyone my name is
specialist Eric champagne retired United
States Army I served honorably from 2009
to
2015 when I was medically retired after
being injured during a tour in
Afghanistan in 2013
I came back stat side and went on to
spend two years in the Wounded Warrior
Center in Fort Drum New York I spent
months learning how to walk again
underwent surgeries and learned to cope
with a whole new way of life when I
retired I was evaluated and put on the
permanent and total disability
list when I returned home to New
Hampshire I had no idea I would be
fighting another War one of which most
years in our current courts I'm a loving
father of two beautiful girls one of
which after more than two years of Court
proceedings I have 5050 custody of I am
very happy to have my daughters in my
life and I felt like I could I could
finally be a parent unfortunately I was
not prepared for the next
obstacle I'd be facing I thought when I
returned home my state would be proud
and thankful to all of our veterans for
overseas just as proud as I
was raised to be however I found faults
in the state of New
Hampshire I have found faults the state
of New Hampshire has illegally according
according to federal law than
considering disability compensation and
child support C
calculation this is against uh federal
law and the apportionment process and
proceedings not only has this completely
drained my finances as well as many
others who proudly sered but it has left
me paying
$1,275 a month in child support alone I
have spent years digging myself out of
debt that seems to never be ending on
top of dealing with my
disability and is exhausted I have job
limitations due to the disabilities
being so severe and an inability to work
at times this leaves me relying on
social security benefits to assist me
financially after my child support
obligations come out I receive
$411 a month to live on my mortgage and
that until the crippling effects of this
Federal L illegal action ceases myself
as well as many other veterans who have
been stripped of our rights to doe
process will be forced to choose between
paying their bills or seeing their child
honestly being raised here our state has
is better than this our soldiers deserve
better and as far as the title 4D office
needing the money as was stated last
year I believe that counting illegal
funds in their budget to begin with
15,432 this year in child in Social
Security benefits a and I have only seen
$628 and6 Cents Only less than half and
I would like to see the people in that
off
that uh that is it for my testimony if
anybody has questions I would be more
than happy to answer
champagne representative
Banger not a question Madam chair just a
statement just wanted to uh thank
you there any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much Mr
you up next is Bjorn
okay I don't see them on the list
here Madam chair yes if when they begin
to speak if they will share if they have
a written
testimony definitely thank you I I
apologize I forgot it's okay thank
you up next is Jesse
Bolan to speak in opposition for four
minutes could you please State who you
are where you're from and who you are
representing and whether or not you have
written
testimony hi my name's Jesse Bolan I'm
representing myself I live in Manchester
New
Hampshire um did I miss did I miss
anything do you have written testimony I
do have written testimony that I can
share once I've said it and send to the
email group if that's okay that would be
great thank you very much thank
you so as I stated my name is Jesse
Bolan and I'd like to start out by
expressing my most sincere appreciation
for veterans that have served this
country prior to you know and and to PR
preserve our freedom and way in life so
thank you and I'd also like to thank the
committee members for the opportunity to
express my thoughts and feelings and
also to hold a separate session um so we
did have time to do this um I'm just
going to briefly explain why I'm in
composition to the bill as the language
states in the proposed Bill HB 317 seeks
to eliminate counting disabled veterans
income as gross income and when reading
the text of the two reference laws 42
USC section 659 and IM
9803 HB 317 would dramatically change
the existing process for New Hampshire
in calculating child support when either
party is receiving disabled veteran
compensation essentially taking the
power out of the hands of the family
court for resolving paid disparities and
putting that burden directly on the
taxpayers of New Hampshire for example
if a 100% disabled veteran receives all
of their income from the from the
government the other party would have to
seek aid from the state of New Hampshire
instead in the way of tanif or similar
funds so I would put this question
before the committee do you believe it
is the responsibility of all New
Hampshire taxpayers to pay child support
to the ex spouse of a disabled veteran
and so if the answer is no I would
implore you to vote in expedient to
legislate on HB
317 so next the New Hampshire Supreme
Court has already ruled on this matter
just about a year ago on this EX in this
exact case in reference to in the matter
of Shawn bronstein and jerich bronstein
the New Hampshire Supreme Court roundly
dismissed the case presented by Shawn
bronstein who who also happens to be the
original author of HB 317 by referencing
existing precedent in both New Hampshire
and federal cases in essence the New
Hampshire Supreme Court found no
existing laws whether federal or in the
state of New Hampshire meant to exempt
any compensation to Veterans from Child
Support I've already submitted this as
evidence to the committee for review and
support of these
statements
so passage of the HB 317 would have an
adverse effect on New Hampshire
residents most directly those who
receive child support uh will find that
support disappear and because income
from all sources is considered when
calculating child support if the
ex-spouse of a disabled veteran happens
to be May making more than the vet it's
possible they would have to pay child
support to the disabled veteran however
by this logic people who make less would
see their support cut and those barely
making ends meet now may face dire
repercussions so and when those people
have nowhere else to go they will
utilize New Hampshire Support Services
costing New Hampshire
taxpayers um
lastly I have known Shawn bronstein for
many years Jerica Shan's ex-wife who
testified in the first hearing on this
bill Mr Bolan this is not about Mr
brunstein you're here to speak about the
bill I understand that um but basically
what I'm trying to get at is um that the
bill before this committee was written
in spite of the fact that he could not
get out of paying child support
and yes he is a disabled Mr Bolan I I
have to ask you you can't make those
statements about another person you're
here to speak about the bill and we'll
decide whether the bill has Merit or not
not whether it was written in spite or
not okay I understand that um then I
will just at that point um I again
restate that in New Hampshire state law
um they did say in rejecting the
argument that was brought before in Rose
V Rose um it is to reject the argument
that it's a federal law to pay to exempt
child support um by avoiding the
possibility of Veterans Administration
being placed in the position as a
collection agency and to prevent the
deprivation and depletion of the means
of substance to Veterans dependent upon
these benefits as the main source of
their
income um so I mean anybody quoting
Federal precedent is ignoring the fact
that the Supreme Court of New Hampshire
has already ruled on it and has put lots
of time and effort and precedent listed
in that ruling which has been sent to
you so thank you for your time I
apologize for having gone in the wrong
direction I've never testified before a
court before so I apologize thank you
thank you very much um are there any
Bolan okay seeing none thank you very
much uh excuse me Madam
chair um
yes um I I actually had a had a question
champ no questions come from the
audience
uh okay um but there our systems Mr
testified up next is Sean
brunstein who's asked for three minutes
could you please
State who you are where you're from and
who you are representing and whether or
Mr can you hear me
okay yes could you please State who you
are where you're from and who you're
representing and whether or not you have
written testimony and you have asked for
three
minutes yes ma'am um before I do that we
actually um from the last bill we were
supposed to have Carson Tucker um
finishes testimony because he was cut
off and I'm going in the order down my
thing and I had told Mr Tucker last time
he could not have an hour and now he's
asked for 30 more minutes so when Mr
Tucker is actually after you okay thank
you madam chair I appreciate that uh my
name is Sean brunstein um I am a
resident of hooks in New Hampshire and I
am testifying um to this bill on behalf
of myself and several other disabled
veterans
um and I
am I did submit a written testimony to
the committee as
well um thank you for your time in
reviewing this bill uh my name is Shan
bronstein and I a disabled veteran and
retired federal employee you've recently
heard testimony from my ex-wife jerich
bronstein while I disagree with certain
aspects of her testimony it has come is
not seen as portraying an accurate view
she has she
Mr brunstein I would just ask that you
speak to the bill yes yes ma'am I am I I
I am stating
that I am not here to provide details of
my contentious divorce um but I am here
to bring Insight on how my rights were
impacted to address the elephant in the
room this bill is not about not wanting
to pay child support at no time did I or
any veteran refuse to pay child support
in particular the case which I filed
the um for the enforcement it was an
appeal that they would not enforce the
order at child support unfortunately
this was false after nearly 18 months of
asking the state of New Hampshire T Ford
agency to file an apportionment they
finally did file the apportionment but
they failed to file it correctly
Department of Veterans Affairs requested
them to provide the correct form
unfortunately the state and my ex-wife
did not provide this
information and when I asked him to
submit it again it was refused and it
was stated it was inappropriate and
redundant to ask for a second request
how is this due process these documents
were submitted to you previously which
shows that the Department of Veterans
Affairs asked the state to complete the
apportionment process in which they have
not done
so this bill provides due process which
is protected under the Fifth Amendment
of the US Constitution and the 14th
Amendment of the New Hampshire
Constitution it puts New Hampshire back
in line with the federal laws and it
provides a legitimate Avenue to seek a
portion of federal benefits which are
protected many people have read the
decision from both the lower courts and
the New Hampshire courts regarding my
personal case but they did not take the
time to actually research the laws that
the both the courts pointed to for
example in the lower court the judge
stated she was following the current
state legislature that was produced this
is correct she refused to comment on
federal law the New Hampshire Supreme
Court used old Federal statutes
specifically 38311
a which was changed after the veteran
judicial review Act of 1988 to
38531 essentially the New Hampshire
Supreme Court cited Federal statutes
that are now considered vocational
rehabilitation veterans are not asking
to not pay child support but they are
asking for your help to enforce
protection on their benefits with regard
to taking into consideration that many
of their injuries impact their daily
living and not everything is covered by
the VA the funds are protected and are
to be used for this purpose
that completes my testimony I've already
submitted written documentation to you
as well and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you may have are there
much up next is Carson Tucker and Mr
Tucker I know you've asked for 30
minutes but I'm going to give you 15
minutes because you had time
before and we have a lot of business to
cover today yeah I appreciate that I
don't think I asked I'm sorry if it's
appeared that I asked for 30 minutes I'm
fine with 15 it's perfect um and I can
you just State who you are where you're
from and who you're representing and
whether or not you have written
testimony yes ma'am I have submitted a
written statement I hope that you've all
had an opportunity to look at that it's
uh and some other materials that are
supporting that written statement um I
sent it to the email that was um
provided I've also I'm a attorney um
former Judge Advocate General with the
Army for 12 years also with the United
States Navy enlisted uh before that uh
for 14 years and um I'm admitted to the
United States Supreme Court I'm an
appell at attorney since I quote unquote
retired uh started my solo practice I
have been representing disabled veterans
across the country um I've also started
um an organization that assists uh the
uh defense of disabled veterans and
Veterans rights generally across the
United States in terms of um the issues
that you guys are discussing today with
HP
317 um I as I testified last time and
and I'm very happy to pick up where I
left off because I think uh I would love
to answer some of the um questions and
and essentially uh questions from anyone
that has any questions from the
committee I would really really be happy
to do that because I think it's always
great with oral argument in court and as
well in these testimony situations when
people ask questions we get a lot of
information out of that so I'll try to
be brief with the remainder of my
testimony and I want to respond to one
thing um regarding whether or not and to
what extent your recognition of
preemptive federal law would actually be
a burden on taxpayers of the State of
New Hampshire uh statistically as we
spoke last time nationally 70% of the
disabled veterans in the United States
of which there are five million or 70%
or greater disabled however there's only
approximately 3,500 disabled veterans in
the state of New Hampshire uh of that
amount uh I assure you if you were to
follow Federal statutes as the HB 317
request it would not be a burden on
state of New Hampshire taxpayers
whatsoever because federal law under the
provisions that were post 1987 which is
post Rose versus Rose the Congressional
statutes cited in my statement 42 USC
659 38 USC 5301 and the regulations that
are also cited provide through the
federal Appropriations process right
Federal money is appropriated by
Congress every single year for purposes
of paying disabled veterans the
disability pay to which they are
entitled and also to pay the dependence
of disabled veterans um for the support
requirements that they have this is why
it's required to go to the VA to request
that they make an apportionment of these
benefits that they have appropriated
through Federal taxpayer dollars to pay
to the disabled veterans and their
dependents all the HB 317 does is is
defer which it has to under the veterans
judicial review act which again was
passed post Rose versus Rose in 1988 to
the VA secretary for making those
determinations 38 USC 511 provides that
the VA has exclusive jurisdiction over
all questions of Law and of fact with
respect to claims for benefits by
dependence exclusive jurisdiction after
Rose Congress removed the concurrent
jurisdiction that the state courts had
to make those determinations precisely
because it was economically burdensome
on the federal government and the
Appropriations Provisions by Congress to
provide disabled veterans for the
benefits to which they are entitled so
federal law has these Provisions the
apportionment process 38 USC
5307 allows for the VA to apportion
benefits and pay those dependence
support uh orders and obligations that
they're entitled to if they show a need
but that need has to be litigated
through the J the exclusive jurisdiction
of the VA which is why it's set up that
way Congress even created a separate
article one court that is uh for all
appeals of these questions have to go
through that article one court it's the
board of veterans appeals then the court
of claims then it's the federal circuit
and then it's the Supreme Court so if
there are any um issues which with a
denial of an apportionment claim then
article one federal court was created to
exclusively address those claims that's
important it's like a lot like
bankruptcy right when you have bankrupt
rupes the federal courts take exclusive
jurisdiction over all questions of
bankruptcy state courts do not have a
concurrent jurisdiction any longer and
that's the significance of the changes
that Congress made uh after Rose versus
Rose which again as I said last time did
previously as an anomaly hold that the
states were not preempted and I think
it's important for the committee to
understand under the Constitutional
structure uh these laws that are passed
providing disability benefits are passed
pursuant to congress's enumerated
military powers under the Constitution
and once that is done once that source
of law has been established and has been
numerous times by the United States
Supreme Court and and United States
versus Oregon is one of the cases
mccardy versus mccardy Ridgeway uh Manel
versus Manel Howell versus Howell
Hillman versus maretta numerous cases
throughout um the last 200 years have
demonstrated that the exercise by
Congress of its enumerated military
Powers is the source of law for these
disability benefits that are paid to
veterans that means that the supremacy
clause preempts all state law that
stands in its way including judicial law
so to the extent that the state of New
Hampshire or any other state supreme
court um disagrees I think that the
legislature of the state certainly has
the authority to defer to the Congress
which is the the federal legislature and
its enumerated Authority Under the
Constitution and the supremacy clause so
and I just want to assure everyone that
there are Provisions for veterans and
the dependence of veterans to be uh
taken care of it just has to come from a
regulated Authority that has the
exclusive jurisdiction to make that
determination otherwise you upset the
balance Buchanan versus Alexander is a
case which uh really highlights this the
reasoning in that case behind the
deference that state courts owe to the
federal government when they are
addressing and dividing Federal
Appropriations must be adhered to
otherwise the federal government's
Authority and power would be uh
basically left to the discretion of 50
states and territories right so if the
states could come in and divide up these
monies as they saw fit in the manner in
which they believe they can um then it
would really throw um throw the uh the f
Appropriations process into disarray and
I believe if you read the plain language
of the statutes I've provided you will
see how this deference to the federal
Authority is set up and established and
structured under the
Constitution um so really that's all I
have to say in that regard uh Federal
preemption applies the state has the
discretion and Authority certainly to um
make sure that it that the state of New
Hampshire is in line with federal law
and preemptive federal law under the the
Constitution and um you know to the
extent that uh Howell versus Howell
which is the 2017 Supreme Court case on
unanimous opinion in which I wrote the
amikas brief for Veterans of Foreign
Wars uh was completely and 100%
consistent with not only Rose versus
Rose but also the current status of
these Federal statutes it basically said
the states remain free to take account
of the fact that some military
retirement pay and dis ility retirement
pay might be U divided by and between
the former spouse and the military a
former military service member through
purposes in in either child support
alimony or property right but it has to
be established by the federal statutes
and that's very significant because I I
would like for the committee also to
understand something very important you
know in the percentages of disabled
veterans these days a lot of people I
think 10 20 years ago look at veterans
and say okay that's a retired veteran he
or she spent 20 or more years as a
service member they have a full-fledged
basic retirement pension and they might
have some disability the types of
benefits that we're talking about are
100% pure disability pay they're not
retirement benefits 90 uh 90% of the
veterans that are disabled that come
have that are present right now in the
United States are not of those who have
retired they're not retirees they don't
even have a retirement pension a
disability retirement pension and again
it's a bit confusing sometimes because
these these these Provisions um that are
established by federal law the
percentages that are out there it's
difficult because some of these
categories are hard to understand but
100% pure VA disability R uh I'm sorry
VA disability pay is not retirement pay
it has nothing to do with retirement pay
at all it's a disability compensation
that's paid to the veteran as a result
of their service connected disabilities
regardless of whether or not they uh had
enough years in service to retire it's
completely different fund and that's why
it has to be sequestered and that's why
the VA retains exclusive Authority and
final jurisdictional control over the
disposition of those benefits and the
states frankly are just not respecting
that and that's the challenge we had in
Howell I mean Howell the US Supreme
Court overturned 30 years of state court
case law that was um was being um
adjudicated that was contrary to Federal
statutes and federal law and it I'm not
surprised I mean I'm not surprised that
we're in this situation today with
respect to the child support and the
spousal support because the states
generally are going to adjudicate this
in a manner that they believe is
favorable uh but in fact is contrary to
federal law and it just is the reality
so um you know it's a state-by-state
battle essentially and I do think the
legislature has the authority the power
and the ability to go and look at these
Federal statutes to recognize the
hierarchy of authority and control under
the supremacy clause and to uh to abide
by the supremacy clause and the federal
statutes that are on the books that
again are post Rose versus Rose 1987
Rose versus Rose has been legislatively
abrogated by the federal statute which
means that they must be respected
regardless of what um the US Supreme
Court said in
1987 so if there's any questions I'd be
happy to answer them again I think
that's very uh fruitful if if there are
if not um um close my testimony thank
you so much for having
me thank you are there any questions
from Mr
Tucker representative
long thank you madam chair uh thank you
uh Mr Tucker uh are you of any other
state that has this
um this uh benefit this waiver of Child
Support so there are some statutes in
some states that recognize uh
that they must abide by the federal
statutes so yes the Texas for example if
you look at um and I don't have the
references to the precise statutes but
some of the state statutes say they must
abide by the federal law which Rich
which essentially defers to the Defense
Finance and Accounting Service to pay
directly to the forer spouse and or the
dependant the amount of money to which
they are entitled and again this if it
comes from the federal um def defas
right defense Finance and Accounting
Service they will only pay that to which
the former spouse or the dependents are
entitled and that's fine that's how it
should be because the VA knows and
determines uh you know what benefits are
available to dependents and to the
veterans and to the veterans former
spouses um and as far but there's none
so there's no other um can I can I have
a followup followup representative yeah
thank you madam chair uh so I'm not
hearing a yes so I'm going to take it as
a no uh the second question I have is
with respect to service connected
disability the uh dependent compensation
would that also be
waved uh with respect to
317 when you say waved I think 317
defers to the federal government to
request from the VA the the amount of
apportionment of those benefits that
should be paid to the dependent so I I'm
not sure what you mean by way
representative long uh that would not be
included in in the calculation of Child
Support HB 317 would defer to the VA to
determine through the apportionment
process as it should what benefits are
being paid to the veteran should be a
available or made available to the um
the former spouse and or the dependents
now remember the federal law 42 USC 659
H1B um 2 I'm sorry H1 a25 and H1 B3 42
USC USC
659 uh defines what is income and what
is not income and h12 A5 actually
defines uh what is income and what the
federal government will count as income
for purposes of child support and
spousal support payments that's already
established by federal law that's why if
you defer to the VA and defas as to what
is available they will see that
recognize it and pay it over pursuant to
a court order uh under H1 B3 however the
amounts that we're talking about the
pure VA disability pay uh 100%
disability payments compensation are
excluded they're not counted as income
so the federal government and the VA to
which it should be the Deferred
Authority uh deferred to um would not
pay that thank you yeah 31 you very much
representative
Lichfield thank you madam chair my name
is representative Melissa Lichfield I am
in the L room I am here with three
fellow Representatives re luii
representative rice and representative D
Simone Mr Tucker first um first I just
want to say that um I feel that the Vets
are very lucky to have you on their side
um and I want to say that I'm super
grateful to all the vets that are out
there for their service um or I wouldn't
be sitting here
today I also want to start by saying
that all humans are equally important
representative liy you have to have a
question oh I'm sorry my question to you
is I am just curious when we are talking
about these child support obligations
are these children any child born to
this veteran or is this any child that
is born prior to the disability or does
it also include any children born after
the
disability so the veterans have an
obligation to report and record the
quote unquote qualified dependence that
they have and that they obviously rely
upon the federal government and the VA
to determine the benefit structure and
the amount of payments they should get
so it applies to anyone that's a
qualified defined dependent under
federal law if a veteran has an a you
know a a child whether it's uh out of
wedlock or from a marriage um a minor
child or a quote unquote qualified
dependent they are going to report that
to the um federal government they're
required to by law I hope that answers
your question it would include any
dependent of a veteran service connected
dis disabled veteran or a retiree or any
veteran service member or any service
member actually Madam chair may I follow
up follow up thank you um Mr Tucker my
question is not whether or not a child
is out of wedlock I feel that that is
irrelevant to the topic my question is
whether or not this child was born after
this veteran knew that they were
receiving disability
benefits yes the child would be included
as a quote unquote dependent of the
veteran if it's a child of the veteran I
I wasn't I didn't mean to make a
distinction I'm just what I mean is the
dependant or minor children born to the
veterans um or considered dependents and
they're entitled to uh benefits the
veterans have the obligation but in fact
there's they're incentivized to report
their dependence to the to the VA so
they're all there's no you know there's
no um reason to exclude
them thank you very much are there any
other questions for Mr Tucker
representative
lii uh thank you Mr
Tucker um I assume that you understand
our dilemma these children have to be
taken care of and we cannot make
distinctions in law between uh one child
and another which uh they have to be
supported and so how are we going to
support them and how are we going to
have one law for all of the people in
this state so this is my experience and
I'm very happy to answer that because my
experience with pre-divorce or or
current uh family law matters throughout
the states is this we approach the um
the judge and the former spouse we
provide them with the forms that are
required by the VA to be filled out to
request the apportionment of Mr Tucker
we we understand the process but just
directly answer his question I'm
answering it so the VA will make the
determination and it works through that
process it's a 317 requires the courts
to request the apportionment the
apportionment will provide the
dependence with the support that they're
required to to to to have according to
the the calculations of the VA so yeah I
mean there's there's provision for it
it's in the bill and I think it
certainly needs to um to be understood
that that bill uh references that it
defers to the VA and there are
Provisions for dependence to be taken
care of so it's not like you're
excluding them 100% altogether by virtue
of this bill uh it the process actually
works uh we've seen it
work
followup are there any more questions
representative
Banger uh thank you madam chair uh Mr
Tucker you stated that there was only a
small portion of disabled veterans in
New Hampshire can you provide to this
committee the possible number of those
disabled veterans who are affected by a
child support payment yeah so I I don't
have that EX exact number but you can
imagine that the subset of the disabled
veterans population in New Hampshire is
that are affected by this is actually
probably percentage wise small which is
sort of good and sort of bad right it's
unfortunate because we don't get a lot
of attention um because in each case in
each state uh some states like Florida
Colorado California have a huge number
of veterans uh disabled veterans but but
we're talking about New Hampshire and I
believe that you answered his question
questions thank you very much Mr
everyone up next is Warren Perry who has
asked for 10 minutes Mr Perry could you
please State who you are where you're
from and who you are representing and
whether or not you have written
testimony thank you madam chair my name
is Warren Perry I'm the deputy agitant
general for New Hampshire's Department
of military Affairs and veteran services
I am located in my office in conquered I
did support I did submit written
testimony uh I I would like to start by
saying you know based on our extensive
research uh well actually let me back up
uh you know our the charge of the
department is to support service members
veterans and their families uh and we
take that that responsibility very very
seriously uh and we understand the uh uh
the ex the importance of this bill and
having good honest debate about uh the
bill on both sides the department is not
taking a position rather our intent is
just to educate you based on our
research and our understanding of the
issue based on our research uh we have
determined that New Hampshire's
consideration of VA disability payments
as part of gross income when determining
the amount of child support is fully
compliant with federal
law VA disability benefits are
compensation for the veterans impaired
earning Camp uh cap capacity and is
intended to support the veteran and
their family so from that regard we can
determine that it's it should be counted
as gross income when determining child
support payments you heard some
testimony previously from representative
Graham and in his written testimony he
put a schedule of payments that that uh
described both with dependent and
without dependent
rates uh in terms of the payment uh
benefits to Veterans with their
disability passing this law would uh
would therefore exclude the intended
purpose right the with dependent rate
part of that since it's included
intended for the family this law would
effectively exclude the calculation of
child support payments uh those VA dis
ility benefits that are intended for the
family
so uh you know again we reassert that
we're fully compliant with federal law
and the disability payments for veterans
with dependence is intended to support
the veteran and the family we know this
is a again an emotional issue you're
going to hear terms like disabled
veterans we certainly appreciate the
sacrifice that all veterans have made
you'll hear terms like child support
what a veteran is and disability rating
there should be a distinction made
between a disabled veteran and a
disability rating uh in my written
testimony I point out that there are
some currently serving members of the
New Hampshire National Guard who have a
100% disability rating but it doesn't
mean necessarily that they're disabled
the intent the impact of this law would
be to exclude that person who is still
uh living a uh uh a meaningful active
life from these payments
right so or from the calculation of
child support in these
payments so again I think it's it's uh
and I appreciate Mr Tucker's testimony
uh I think it's clear that we need to
continue to separate uh the issue of
alimony or ex spousal support and child
support the law is pretty clear about ex
spousal support and defines dependent as
a family member the ex spouse is no
longer a family member or dependent
therefore the disability payment is
excluded in that alimony piece but it's
still absolutely compliant with federal
law to include disability payments
when uh uh considering child
support uh the apportionment process is
uh to my mind our is is our
understanding of the apportionment
process is that is a is a form of
redress for the affected
parent uh or the affected child it's not
intended to be the
process uh apportionment occurs or is uh
you know a person is eligible for the
apportionment process so when an
obligation is not being met so
eliminating the
obligation would would almost certainly
eliminate eliminate uh the right to a
portion so if there's no court order
ordering the child support there would
be no basis for making an apportionment
claim so I know it's it's a it's a
complicated process but that's that is
our understanding of this uh so and and
again this bill is not really about a
portion apportionment is a process that
occurs when uh when an obligation is not
being met so you know there has to be an
obligation to pay child support before
the abortion process can
start
uh I would say I don't envy the uh uh
the position that the the the committee
is in and I appreciate their considered
uh you know they're they're passionate
and considered opinion uh when they when
they choose to vote uh on this
bill but you have to you know our
position is we are federal law and Court
precedent make it absolutely clear that
it's permissible for the state to
include veterans disability payments
when calculating child
support I want you to understand that VA
disability payments
as uh as cited in court precedent are
you know and they cite the intent of
Congress that those payments are made
for the family and the veteran not just
for the
veteran alimon and uh alimony or ex
espousal support and child support are
separate
issues Rose versus Rose is clear Court
precedent and it remains current today
in fact uh you know part of uh
part of the the court case of Mr
bronstein and if if you would just
indulge me for a second I'd like to read
you just the passage with regard to
Howell versus how you heard testimony
early
about and it and I'm quoting from the
brunstein case and it says husband is
also M mistaken to the extent that he
argues how versus
Howell uh abrogated Rose or or
overturned Rose how will address the
treatment of the division of military
benefits as property and a divorce not
as income to support the Veteran's
dependence Howell did not address the
calculation of a veteran's income for
child support
purposes and then it goes on to say
nothing in Howell Alters Rose are the
holding and Rose that military
disability benefits are not required to
be excluded from the definition of
income for the purpose of calculating
resources a party can draw on to fulfill
child support
obligations so if uh and again I don't
want to to rehear brunstein that's not
my intent or rehear Rose I just want to
say that was the decision and we
generally follow the decision of the
courts when they rule on matters of law
uh I would like to just address the fact
that we did some research on other
states uh and we found that of the 50
states no State expressly excluded the
inclusion of veterans disability and the
calculation of child support in fact 29
States including New Hampshire expressly
include
them 14 States uh include the disability
benefits generally but not expressly
include them and it was not addressed in
eight states so there are no States
right now that are currently not
calculating uh veterans disability
benefits when we're determining gross
support and uh I will just uh I did
submit my written testimony I hope that
you had an opportunity to review it I'm
happy to answer any
question thank you very much so I have
um like two questions and bear with me
because I I don't know a lot about this
but so whose responsibility is it to
apply for an
apportionment the affected parent or the
affected party
so it's not the state of New Hampshire
or the division of child support my
understanding is the initiation of the
apportionment process starts with the
affected parent and is assisted by the
Bureau of uh uh child services at uh at
DHHS uh I'm not an expert on that on how
it the process initiates I know that
Karen Hebert is going to testify uh
sometime this morning and she may be
able to answer that question more in a
more detailed manner thank you and just
one more thing so this bill does not
force the state to request an
apportionment is that
correct I I don't I don't see that in
there I think the effect of this bill
ma'am is to eliminate disability
payments within the calculation of for
child support is gross income for child
support I don't see any part of this
bill that would have the effect of uh uh
of requiring the state to request a
apportionment uh I just think it would
be and and I think it would be a process
that would be arduous it would be
another step in the process you know my
understanding of the issue is that the
federal government really defers to the
States on a matter of family law and uh
you know trying to put the federal
government in that process is is a
little bit awkward to to my way of
thinking I mean after I served for 28
years in the Army and you know we have
rules about child support and other
things and making sure that soldiers are
meeting their obligations when they're
still serving and again the military
prefers to let the that be a process
between the parties or the courts so you
know I don't I don't see this law as you
know is is giving a requirement to the
states to do
apportionment I see it more as a fact
that we're just going to exclude the
disability payments from the calculation
of gross income
okay thank you representative
Banger thank you madam chair uh Mr Perry
uh question for you sir obviously in
regards to payments when a soldier um is
considered
disabled and there is obviously a
calculation as to how much this um
disabled v may receive per dependent um
is that taken into consideration when
making child support payments for
example if a child's payment is is if
each if the veteran is receiving aund
I'm just going to pull a random number
here $9 per
dependent is that um is is that disabled
veteran uh paying more than that $19
from child support payments thank thank
you for your question I'm going to
clarify it so what you're asking is is
the difference between the dependent
rate and the without without dependent
rate the only thing considered in the
gross income can you clarify that that's
your question pretty much yeah so the
answer is the it'll be the gross income
I believe so the C the calculation for
child support and again the folks Karen
Heber can answer the question better but
it's gross income so the entire
disability payment would be considered
as the gross income and then the
percentage of that based on the formulas
uh that are that are made by the state
would be the amount of payment that
would be uh determined the amount of
child support payment that would be
you are there any other questions from
Mr
Perry up next is Karen Hebert who has
asked for 10 minutes could you please
State who you are where you're from and
who you are representing and whether or
not you have given written testimony
thank you on behalf of the Department of
Health and Human Services and the Bureau
of Child Support Services my name is
Karen Hebert I am the bureau chief and
the State child support director and I
am in my conquered office uh testifying
today I did provide written testimony to
the
committee thank you go
ahead thank you it is my intention to
provide the committee with information
that will Aid in your decision making um
I want the committee to know the
department um believes you should be
fully informed with respect to the
impacts of this particular bill I will
say that the department honors and
respects the commitment that veterans
made in order for child support in New
Hampshire is determined using the New
Hampshire child support guidelines and
that is under statutory Authority the
New Hampshire guidelines statute defines
gross income very broadly as all income
from any Source whether earned or
unearned which language follows federal
child support
regulation the federal child support
regulation is a requirement in the child
support state plan which is subject to
Federal audit and which the state is
currently in compliance
with this federal child support
regulation requires that the state's
child support guidelines must provide
that the child support order is based on
the obligor parents earnings income and
other evidence of ability to pay that
takes into consideration all earnings
and income of the obligor parent
basically the state must comply with all
federal regulations in the state plan in
order to receive title four that's a
Roman numeral for uh D under the Social
Security Act title 4D Federal funding
and federal resources and to avoid
fiscal
penalties the state of New Hampshire
relies on federal funding and federal
resources that provide critical data and
support and sources for child support
collections the state would not be able
to successfully serve families without
this funding and resources New Hampshire
receives approximately 11.8 million each
year from the federal government which
pays for over 2third of the cost of the
state
program the federal government also
provides data to the state for example
Federal new hire information it provides
direct support and resources to our
employer community and it provides the
treasury offset program which is a major
source of Child Support collected for
families which was in fiscal year 20
$13.6 million
New Hampshire courts also receive
federal title for defunding to establish
and maintain expedit processes for the
establishment of child support orders
with this funding and resources the
state is effectively able to collect
over $80 million each year for
approximately 40,000
children at present the state is in
compliance with the federal law and
regulation as determined by the federal
government and is evident by the fact
the state continues to receive title 4D
Federal funding and access to those
resources excluding veterans disability
benefits from gross income in the
determination of Child Support Awards
would also subject the state to other
Federal sanctions which are fiscal
penalties of up to $1.9
million assessed every year against the
state's tanith block grant as long as
the state is not in compliance with the
Federal Authority if this bill passes
the state will not be in compliance and
will risk the penalty
assessment the amount of child support
in certain cases will decrease if this
bill is passed which will results in
more families relying on public
assistance as was mentioned in earlier
testimony this creates a greater burden
on assistance programs in the state and
on
taxpayers excluding veteran disability
benefits from gross income will also
negatively impact the Department's
ability to recover Public Assistance
expenditures in cases where child
support is assigned to the department
this is an important responsibility of
the child support
program the passing of this bill would
ultimately reduce the amount of child
receive the bill would be particularly
impactful on recipient families whose
come is below the poverty level and for
whom child support is often most if not
their only source of income according to
a 2018 study in New
Hampshire I ask that you consider the
following veterans with child dependence
who have a disability rating of 60% or
less receive a benefit amount that is
less than the guidelines current
self-support Reserve amount if this is a
veteran's sole source of income
the child support obligation is $50 a
month which is the statutory minimum
however veterans with child dependents
who have a disability rating that is
greater than 60% would receive a monthly
benefit amount greater than the
self-support reserve amount and thus be
liable for support in New Hampshire laws
and the current
guidelines for
example the guideline self-support
Reserve is presently one
$1,223 a
month let's assume that the sole income
of the veteran is the Veteran's
disability benefit for the veteran with
children and let's just say that their
benefit is at a 100% disability rate
their benefit amount would be
$3,263 74 a
month under the current
guidelines the amount for the family of
Child Support award would be $668 a
month under the proposed Bill the
guidelines amount would be $50 a
month if this bill passes children whose
veteran parent is earning an amount
greater than the self-support reserve
would lose the financial support they
would otherwise receive under the
current
statute the calculation of Child Support
is the target subject of this bill which
is separate and distinct from federal
and state Authority on
garnishment the federal and state
Authority and case law on child support
garnishment state that while veterans
disability benefits are exempt from
garnishment directly to the VA once
these funds are received by the veteran
they can be used to satisfy a state's
order of Child
Support there is an exception to the
garnishment through the vet through the
VA that is provided for in federal
policy guidance that was released after
Federal memorandum in
1998 that was issued by the
administration for Children and Families
it includes instructions to States on
how to send an income withholding
garnishment to the
VA including veterans disabilities and
the definition of gross income to both
determine a support obligation amount
and to satisfy a support obligation are
absolutely Allowed by federal law and in
accordance with federal and state case
law so how do we help veterans
now the Department of Health and Human
Services looks for ways to engage with
and work with parents including veterans
who want to support their children but
are experiencing barriers to comply with
the Court's order in other words paying
their child
support the department is currently
helping these parents using a variety of
methods in including Outreach activities
and intervention services and connecting
them with resources that may be
available to them the department uses a
debt reduction program to help address
unmanageable past due child support it
also takes steps to ensure the parent
support order is Right sized and based
on their ability to
pay when any obligor parent does not
have the ability to pay the bureau can
at their request review their
court-ordered amount and the
circumstances that are impacting their
ability to pay if the circumstance
warrants an adjustment of their court
ordered amount the bureau can take it to
court for them and request that the
amount be recalculated based on their
actual income for example if the
original order was issued based on
earnings several years ago while in
active duty at a higher rate of pay but
now the veteran is earning let's say
$1,000 a month and benefits then the
order should be adjusted in accordance
with the current guideline
statute it is the Department's
experience that many paying parents are
not aware they can change their order or
they don't know how to or they cannot
afford the court filing fee we can we
can and do help them with this at no
cost these services are available to
Veterans and if a veteran does not have
a case with the bureau
he or she can contact us and apply for
services even if their order was issued
in another state or even if their order
was issued in another country we can
help them if this bill passes the state
will be at risk of not being able to Pro
to provide these kinds of services that
many parents in addition to Veterans
need thank you for giving me this
time thank you very much um I just have
a quick
question if a parent doesn't initiate
the apportionment process does the
division do that or what happens with
that if if a parent is refusing to start
that
process thank you Madame chairwoman for
your question it's a good question and
there's been um some um a little bit of
confusion with respect to apportionment
and that particular
process um apportionment does not
replace child
support if the receiving parent in our
case in the world of child support the
recipient of Child Support requests
assistance from the bureau to file a
claim of apportionment with the V with
the VA we will file the claim with the
recipient
parent um we have instructions that have
been issued by our federal office
specifically on how to do that
um does does that answer your
question kind of I'm just thinking
because the apportionment would add to
their income and give them money to be
able to pay this child support even if
more would have to come out of their
gross income at least they would have
that little bit of extra so I'm just
it it's entirely up to the recipient
parent to make that request um it
honestly we it's our experience in the
department that we do not
receive that particular request I'm only
aware of one instance where we have
received that request and actually it
was not requested by the recipient
parent it was requested by the paying
parent so it is not a commonly uh
requested um
uh not a common request and I don't I
don't know I don't have any information
if the recipient parent initiates such
requests for apportionment to the VA
directly without the bureau's assistance
that is entirely
possible okay thank you are there any
Hebert seeing none thank you very much
thank
you up next is Matthew Hayes who has
asked for 10 minutes please State who
you are where you're from and who you
are representing and whether or not you
have written
testimony good morning um Madam chairin
Marice and members of the house and
children house children family law
committee on behalf of the Department of
healthy need services and the Bureau of
Child Support Services I thank you for
giving me the opportunity to speak about
HP
3117 U my name is attorney Matthew Hayes
I'm an attorney with the Bureau of Child
Support Services and I have previously
submitted written
testimony I'd like to just start by
talking about the child support uh
process generally to give committee some
additional context um the Social
Security Act
4D P 4D requires that all states follow
Federal rules and regulations when
establishing and enforcing child's cour
orders the Federal Law requires that all
states establish child sport guidelines
for the purposes of establishing those
orders the New Hampshire's child support
guidelines are cified in 4508 C and they
establish a uniform system to determine
child sport Awards the purpose of this
chapter is not only to ensure uniformity
in determining the amount of child
support but also to ensure that both
parents share in that support
responsibility for their children
according to their relative percentage
of each parent's income
there is a rebuttable presumption that
the child support award calculated under
the guidelines is the correct amount of
child support but this presumption may
be overcome and a state court May
deviate from the guidelines when a party
shows uh by a preponderance of evidence
that the application of those guidelines
would be unjust or inappropriate because
circumstances um there is included in
statute a special list or a
non-exclusive list of circumstances that
if raised by any party or the court the
court shall consider in making an
adjustment that departs from the
guidelines uh either downwards or
upwards the New Hampshire Supreme Court
has interpreted special circumstances as
including only circumstances that are
economic in nature and relate to the
impact of a parent's Financial condition
upon his or her ability to meet the
child needs the trial the trial the
trial court must consider any of these
circumstances in light of the best
interests of the
child so with respect to feral law as a
director Heber already pointed out
Federal Law requires that the state use
all forms of income and that those all
forms of income be included in the child
support
guidelines um in accordance with Federal
Authority our statute uses a broad
definition of gross income and the New
Hampshire guidelines specifically
include veterans disability
benefits uh I think it's also important
to acknowledge that the New Hampshire
Supreme Court has
confirmed the inclusion of veterans
disability benefits as income for child
support purposes and that that is
consistent with federal law um veterans
disability benefits as was already
pointed out intended to provide
reasonable and adequate compensation for
both veterans and their families uh the
brunstein case that was uh been cited a
few times is also cites a US Supreme
Court case Rose V rose in which
recognizing that military de Rose
recognizes that again the benefits are
not provided to support the Venture
alone that Congress clearly intended
veterans disability benefits to be used
in part for support veterans
dependence just like also to point out
that the New Hampshire Supreme Court in
bronstein has squarely addressed many of
the issues that were raised previously
today the New Hampshire Supreme Court
has found through its analysis that Rose
has not been overruled and many other
state courts have come to the same
conclusion many of those State Court
decisions are also included in the
bronsteen
decision the committee should also be
aware that the obligor in the Bron Ste
case has appealed that decision to the
US Supreme Court and the Supreme Court
has declined to hear that
case um I know that I've cided some
things that were already discussed
previously so I will just uh I would
like to thank the committee for giving
me the time to speak about this bill I'm
certainly uh open to any questions that
the committee may
have are there any questions from Mr
Hayes
much up next is Timothy
penac um he asked for zero minutes but
I'll give you
five please um State who you are where
you're from and who you are representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony
there okay so then we will go to Moira
Ry
who has asked for zero minutes but I'll
give you five and please State who you
are where you're from and who are you
representing and whether or not you have
written
testimony um yes hi my name is Mora Ryan
um I'm here today to oppose HB 317 FN I
advocate for custodial parents veterans
Excuse Me Miss Ryan can you please State
who you are where you're from and who
you're representing and whether or not
you've given written t testimony sure my
name is Mora Ryan I live in London Dairy
New Hampshire um I represent custodial
veterans military spouses military
dependents um I worked for the VA and I
advocate on behalf of veterans with
apportionment claims which I've been
doing for over a
decade did I answer all your question
and I did submit written testimony I did
submit written testimony yes okay thank
you you have five minutes um I just
wanted
to talk to the committee about the
apportionment process I've worked for
the VA I've been defending veterans
against apportionment claims and also
applying for them on behalf of custodial
parents um the I also worked with the
the VA DC office um and I wanted to
explain what a veteran apportionment is
a veteran apportionment is a process in
which a in a in which a claim filed by
the custodial parent um the custodial
parent request money be paid for the
support of a dependent the apportionment
claims Were Meant to Be an additional
means of enforcement of Child Support
not a substitute or relitigate of a
divorce proceeding the VA has determined
that VA disability is meant for the
support of the veteran and their
dependence as others have said and it's
cited in almost every veteran law
decision from now decades back um VA
General Council has stated that the
purpose of the apportionment is to
effectuate the responsibility of the VA
beneficiary to support the beneficiaries
dependent both the VA the dod and all of
the service branches state that the
parent regardless of service or status
is supposed to support their child um
the VA has the right to determine the
Veteran's obligation Mr Tucker had said
that the VA has the right to determine
the Veteran's obligations but that's
actually not true because the VA
apportionment process actually relies on
the state process so what happens is the
custodial parent will file a request for
apportionment and a general
apportionment is granted Ed if the
not essentially fulfilling their
obligation to support the child and if
the child doesn't live with the veteran
um one of the issues that I've had with
veterans is that they will the the
custodial parent will apply for an
apportionment claim and they will also
be fulfilling their child support
obligations and then I have to go back
and get that money back from the VA and
if there's no state court support order
in place it's going to make it
existentially harder for me to defend
them from people who do that um the fact
that the apportionment process exists is
because it's supposed to support the
state process it's not supposed to
replace it um the same sentiment was
echoed by the Supreme Court in the Rose
V Rose case which is not outdated how V
how Winer V Wisner and many of the other
cases that Mr Tu Tucker had uh cited
specifically referenced alimony and
divorce divorce proceedings where assets
are being divided child support is not
an asset um I agree that the once the
the ex spouse is no longer a part of the
family they're not entitled to support
but the child still is and the veteran
still has an obligation to do that
regardless of their status um all of the
cases that he cited Wisner how they all
specifically state that they're not in
relation to child support the veteran
does have a duty to support defendants
and honestly if you take away Counting
child support or putting in a a court
ordered support
obligation it makes it harder for me to
defend these guys when there are people
who go and apply for an apportionment
claim because in certain States it's
considered a separate stream of Revenue
um I just had a case where I had to go
back and get almost $100,000 for a
veteran where the ex had applied for an
apportionment claim it had been granted
and they were paying all their support
obligations which I actually won that
case um but without being able to show
that there is an
adequate supply of money being given to
the custodial parent it's very difficult
and then it's left up to the Judgment of
someone making that decision um and the
VA has stated that
um an apportionment claim should consist
of 20% to 50% of um the total amount of
VA disability the state does
25% um I wouldn't want to go in and
argue when I could get 25% in a state
court versus going and losing half later
that's a really hard thing for me to to
try and and manage because it's very
very subjective
um the supremacy clause that Mr Tucker
cited does state that federal law
supersedes state law but it also is very
clear that it doesn't involve election
processes divorce proceedings things
like that because those are considered
the purview of the state and the VA
honestly does not want to be involved in
litigating a divorce or determining a
support amount that's not their role
they're not there to do that and they're
not a Judicial body so they can't really
make a determination like that legally
um as I stated um in my written
testimony there are no other states that
have a law like this um and I've been
working on apportionment claims as I
stated on both sides so I will close my
testimony I did submit written testimony
with more information but I would like
to open up to questions if anybody has
any
thank you are there any questions from
Miss
Ryan seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony thank
you okay so that's all I have on my list
for Testimony and I see no hands raised
so I will close the public hearing on HB
then I will give the clerk a few minutes
and we will open the executive section
section the executive session on HB 188
so I'll wait for the clerk to get her
Madam clerk just let me know when you're
ready
okay so I'm going to open the executive
session on House Bill 188 representative
Banger do you have a
[Music]
motion I do Madame chair I make a motion
that we
Simone repres representative long would
you like to introduce an amendment or
anything I would than thank you madam
[Music]
I'd like to introduce Amendment um
03878 would you like to speak to your
amendment I would thank you madam chair
um so the the amendment uh the notice
goes out to The Lawyers it it it
clarifies when a notice will go out
instead of waiting
for uh determining Indigent juvenile the
notice goes out to uh the lawyer
immediately uh and it and it it
qualifies that on the second uh line on
lines
24 and it also allows that if if the
juvenile it it it clearly states that if
the juvenile is not uh found to be be
Indigent then they can back up and not
appoint the lawyer um you know if they
could pick their own lawyer and then
finally
uh and then finally IT addresses it
clarifies better what the courts will be
seeking for payment that it's it's it
clarifies that it it will not seek
attorney payment it'll be fees and
restitution that the juvenile um Court
decided to give towards the juvenile
thank you madam
chair thank you are there any questions
long is there any further discussion on
his
Amendment seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the adoption of
amendment
hold
03878 representative D
Simone
yes uh representative
yella
yes representative Lu wikii yes
representative
Bellinger
yes representative
Marsh
Lichfield
yes representative
Smith
yes I'm sorry there was a little noise
in the background uh representative
Smith please
yes thank you representative long
yes representative Alysa yes
representative
growman
Le
wayon representative way there
sorry yes sorry I had an internet
connection problem for a
minute representative Peto
yes representative Al Chiller
yes Madam chair representative
rice
yes the vote is 15 to
zero 15 to Zer the amendment is adopted
so the motion now is on to pass as
amended is there any further the
discussion Madam
chair who's saying
that representative
yella I'm sorry yes representative
yella thank you um is it my
understanding that this still
um seeks to change how the uh lawyers
are paid from a set stien to an hourly
rate essentially
and
um is that understanding still correct
adopted representative long thank you
madam chair uh the answer is
yes yeah the amendment doesn't change
discussion did and um yella thank you um
we um did we get a uh FN on
this yes it's it was sent to your
email we do not worry about the FN
though that's for finance to worry about
questions seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role the motion is ought to
188 representative D Simone
no representative
lucki
yes representative Banger sorry
yes representative
Marsh
Lichfield
sorry
long
yes representative Aliya yes
representative
grman
yes representative
Le
wayar yes
representative
Petrino
yes Madam chair representative
14 to
Report no so representative Belanger
will write the majority report thank
you okay so I'm going to close the
executive session on House Bill
188 and give the clerk a few minutes
before we go to
254 thank
you pardon me repres representative rice
this is
Christina um time to get um possibly to
get those two bills the the reports
today so that we can yes that's my plan
okay perfect they're already going to
send me they're immediately going to
send me the committee reports and we're
going to get them over there perfect
Madam clerk just let me know when you're
ready
done we can begin
yes okay I'm
ready okay so I just want to address
because we had started this last week
and then we had the the thing where it
just all went away so I'm just going to
have a start from the beginning again
and and then we'll you
know go on from there so um
representative D Simone did you have a
motion thank you madam chair I do I uh
make a motion of ought to
lii did you want to speak to your motion
oh wait a minute
I'm going to introduce an
amendment
okay okay so I'm going to introduce
1-14h which removed the
um um the Care Management
does everybody have it I'm sorry I know
confusing and it it also updated some of
the
offenses that
um kids could not be put
in Center four and it um else did it do
gosh um oh it changed
the we originally were going to have the
detained but we changed the date to six
months out to give the courts and the
cun Center time
to accommodate this and also the
community organizations that will
kids does anybody representative long
did you have a question uh I didn't have
a question did you get a second I'll
second it if you didn't get a second oh
you is there any further discussion on
this seeing none I'll have the clerk
call the role on adopting Amendment 2021
representative D
Simone
yella
yes representative luii
yes representative
Banger
representative
lville
yes representative
Smith
yes representative long
yes representative Alisa yes
representative
Gman
yes representative
L
yeah that was yes yes
correct
yes
representative was wayar
yes representative
patrino yes representative Al
Shiller
yes madame chair rice representative
15 to
zero Christina can this go on consent
even though I'm requesting for it to go
to
finance I don't believe so but I will
double check for you okay I didn't think
it could but I I just wanted to double
check does anyone object to consent if
it can go on
consent representative
yella uh thank you um uh we still
haven't voted on the actual bill we just
voted on the amendment but I want you're
so right thank you I'm sorry and and I
believe that I would object to being on
consent since it is a financial yeah I
don't think it can so that's why but I
wanted to verify it but as as uh in in
reference to the underlying bill now
that we are talking about um OTP as
amended I would like to thank Zoom for
mute thank you I I wanted to uh thank
Zoom for cutting us off last week so
that I had more time to uh look into
this bill and look at all of the um
ramifications and um am now happy to
support the bill so I I just wanted to
shout out uh Zoom for making that happen
okay so now the motion is a to pass is
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
ready Madame chair who made the motion
for
otpa well it continues with
representative D Simone because we
introduced the amendment so just changes
that nobody has to make a a new motion
you rep representative D
Simone
yes representative
yella
yes representative Lui
yes representative
Banger yes representative
Marsh
yes representative
lvi yes representative
Smith
yes representative long
yes representative ala yes
representative
grman
yes representative
patrio
hella
yes
representative Madam chair
representative
rice yes thank
thank you very much um since we have the
time why don't we exec one more real
quick okay um Madam chair I just wanted
to let you know that I did verify that
it cannot go on the consent calendar
great thank you
okay we'll do um House Bill 541 when the
I'm
ready okay thank you representative
liwicki Madam chair I move in expedient
to legislate on
541 is that
seconded
second we second it it please
representative Banger thank
you would you like to speak to your
motion um yes Madam chair um
the I believe that this is an exercise
in futility because a um if somebody
chooses to pay a lawyer directly we
cannot possibly attribute those funds to
discussion okay well seeing none I'll
yes representative
yella
Banger uh
yes representative
rep representative
lville
yes representative
Smith
yes representative long
yes uh representative Alisa
yes representative
L
yes representative way
sorry representative
patrino
yes Madam chair representative
rice
yes it's 15 to zero without
objection this can be placed on the
consent
calendar okay so I'm going to close this
executive session and we will all be
back here at 1:15 thanks so much much
everybody what a great morning thank you
all right let's check this Cy
out
my
e
for
I'll
so Pat just so you know I'm GNA do
because there's 22 people signed up so
I'm going to give them five minutes
instead of the two like we had I had
originally said when I thought it was
going to be yeah many many more okay I I
uh I see that uh representative LSA is
in in the attendees side is that going
to be an
issue yeah why is she over there yeah
she should be in move her hold on I
over when she comes
much oh my God hi guys hi there you are
oh my God I was following the
instructions and I could hear you guys
but I couldn't get in I was like oh my
God happy you're in now thank you so
magic thank you um Ken I'm sorry
representative rice I'm very
sorry yes you'll be so proud all all of
your paperwork is
in I never doubted it for a minute okay
look what I got during lunch oh you guys
were not up close you can't see me
listen my
beans you needed it
right really again you guys though this
morning went so well I'm just so
grateful thanks to
[Music]
welcome
okay so good afternoon everyone welcome
back I hope um everyone had a a great
lunch um so we're gonna do the
um we're going to continue the public
hearing on h68 that we had um started
last week we had um 22 people have
signed up to testify so I'm going to
limit debate to limit testimony to five
minutes and when you have one minute
left representative deimon will hold up
a sign so that you know that so that the
person testifying knows that they have
one minute left um I would ask people
who want to testify to try to touch on
things that we haven't heard before and
not Echo the testimony before them um so
that we get new information every time
okay and you know I'm sorry I I have to
do this but we have a lot of work to do
and some members have to leave by a
certain time today so um we're gonna
Brown would you please State who you are
where you're from who you are
representing and whether or not you have
written
testimony yes thank you um uh Brandy
Brown I'm a licensed clinical social
worker I'm speaking for myself and I did
uh email written testimony to the
committee um last night and where are
you from I'm from
Maine thank you go ahead you have five
I'd like to
express strong opposition to House Bill
68 um an act relative to the definition
of child abuse this dangerous and
misguided legislation targets an already
vulnerable group of New Hampshire Youth
and denies them access to standard
necessary Medical
Care as a program manager and clinical
mental health provider for a large
pediatric gender program in Northern New
England I work with many New Hampshire
children experiencing gender
dysphoria I am the also the current
board president for the National
Association of Social Workers main
chapter as a social worker following the
nasw code of ethics this legislation
would make it impossible for me to meet
my ethical obligations to the children I
serve without violating New Hampshire
law transgender children have the same
needs as any other
children but they are unique because
they're likely to experience a condition
known as gender dysphoria which
manifests as clinical distress caused by
the in congruence between their natal
sex and their gender
identity this is a diagnosis outlined by
the dsm5 that's the diagnostic and
statistical Manual of mental disorders
fifth edition published by the American
Psychiatric association in
2011 an important clinical
characteristic of gender dysphoria is
that clinically significant distress
must be persistent greater than six
months conation and lead to impairment
in multiple
domains transgender children and
Adolescence need access to high quality
evidencebased care for treatment of
gender dysphoria social transition and
in many cases medical transition is
indicated to relieve symptoms of gender
dysphoria by transition I'm referring to
the process of a young person outwardly
living as the gender that they
identify treatment may include any
combination of the following talk
therapy family therapy support groups
social transition puberty blocking or
suppressing medication gender affirming
hormones of testosterone and estrogen
and sometimes surgery please note
there's no medical treatment option for
young children who have not yet reached
puberty best practice guidelines
including the standards of care
published by the world professional
association for transgender Health
referred to as W paath and clinical
practice guidelines published by the end
endocrine
Society highlight the importance of
providing medical treatment for youth
within a multidisciplinary treatment
train setting these are the Prevailing
practice guides in the US and that is
why most major pediatric gender programs
have been established by Leading
Children's Hospitals treatment teams
include Mental Health and Medical
Specialists who have undergone
additional training in this area
treatment decisions are collaboratively
made with the child parents and
Guardians Mental Health and Medical
provider together medical treatment is
only discussed if it is considered
medically necessary after a mental
health evaluation has been completed in
my practice I often schedule additional
appointments to ensure that all of those
involved with the decision are
comfortable with and fully understand
treatment before moving forward I
consult regularly with clinical ethics
and other pediatric teams across the
country this bill is
unconscionable because it puts up a
barrier between parents and their
ability to access medically necessary
healthare for their children
parents would have to choose between
watching their child languish knowing
that in neighboring states they could
receive appropriate Medical Treatments
and compliance with New Hampshire law in
my experience parents seeking healthc
care for their children will go through
Great Lengths to Advocate that their
children have access to highquality
effective evidence-based medicine I urge
you not to silence these families and
limit their options as they seek support
for their
children without access to Quality
Medical Care gender dysphoria can result
in terrible out comes for children up to
and including suicide any decision for a
child or adolescent to stop medical
treatment especially one with such a
significant impact on mental health and
quality of life should be done under the
supervision of a qualified medical
provider with support of a mental health
provider in the past year we have
experienced challenges related to
medication access due to supply
shortages related to the pandemic the
patients who are anticipating treatment
delays displayed considerable anxiety
around the possibility of delay and requ
an increased level of mental health
support to my knowledge there's no
evidence-based practice guide around
abruptly withholding treatment however I
would anticipate significant mental
health decompensation for patients who
are abruptly to lose access to treatment
transgender children and Adolescence
need your time is up can you wrap it up
very
quickly thank you need access to
specialized Medical Care this bill is
designed to prevent them and their
families from accessing the care they
need I urge you to vote unanimously
against the Terrible legislation and
send a message to New Hampshire families
that this committee will not consider
legislation that forces families to risk
everything to provide the healthcare
needs for their children thank you thank
you very much for your testimony are
Brown seeing none thank you very much
thank
you up next is um representative Amanda
tol
thank you please State who you are where
you're from and who you're representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and please um keep in mind you
have five
minutes dear um hello honorable chair
and children and family law committee
members my name is Amanda Elizabeth tol
and I represent Keen at large and I'm
going to be giving spoken testimony
today I strongly oppose
hp68 this bill attempts to add sexual
reassignment to the definition of an
abused child this bill has quite
literally nothing to do with protecting
children from abuse quite the to the
contrary not accepting our children for
who they are and forcing them to be
something they are not is abusive it can
lead to catastrophic outcomes for
transgender youth I got elected on an
intersectional feminist platform that
included glbtq rights bodily autonomy
Domestic and Sexual Violence prevention
and child advocacy I believe that the
vast majority of Granite Staters even
Republican ones who may disagree with me
about things like the size of government
support glbtq plus rights and public
policy aligned with child advocacy this
piece of legislation is really just an
anti- glbtq and anti- youth Rights bill
in Disguise pretending to be something
to help children when it's really
discriminatory and hurtful this bill has
the potential to cause irreparable harm
to trans and gender non-conforming
children the American Academy of
Pediatrics urges support support in care
of transgender and gender diverse
children and Adolescence Jason rafy MD
and the lead author of the American
Academy of pediatric statement says we
know that family and Community Support
are essential for any child's healthy
development and children who are gender
diverse are no different he goes on to
write what is most important is for a
parent to listen respect and support
their children's self-expressed identity
the statement goes on and highlights
that transgender and gender diverse
youth have higher rates of depression
anxiety eating disorder and substance
use self harm and suicide however
children who are supported by their
parents and family are more likely to
experience physical and mental health
the AAP recommends taking a gender
affirming non-judgmental approach that
helps children feel safe in a society
that too often marginalizes or
stigmatizes those seen as different the
AAP emphasizes the gender affirming
model strengthens family resiliency and
takes the emphasis of heightened
concerns over gender while allowing
children the freedom to focus on
academics relationship building and
other typical developmental tasks our
job as legislators is to protect Granite
State kids no matter their identity this
bill does the opposite sadly this bill
showcases the prejudices of fellow
lawmakers and in doing so harms a
vulnerable population thank you for
hearing my testimony I am going to defer
questions to the families directly
harmed by this bill and the healthcare
professionals who serve them thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony and you were deferring
questions
correct correct thank you okay
thanks so up next
is uh Jonah
Davis um please State who you are where
you're from and who you are representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and please remember you have
five
minutes hi my name is Jonna Davis I'm
from Gilford New Hampshire and
representing myself and my
child
um I just wanted to say that
uh I have three children three adult
children uh two of them are were born
female my oldest two were incredibly
happy growing up and there were never
any questions to their identities my
youngest child
Julian Associates as a
male um throughout his life jul Julian
fought his femininity from wearing girl
clothes and playing with girl toys it
was obvious we just didn't see
it I'm sure his teachers saw it and yet
it went unnoticed he climbed trees
searched for bugs played with Ninja
Turtles and through all throughout his
childhood he never invited girls to his
birthday parties his father his father
and I passed him off as a tomboy we
didn't know anything else I wish we knew
then what we know now by middle school
and on many occasions I would come home
from work and he would be crying in his
bedroom I remind you that we raised two
two girl children we knew what normal
was at this age this was not normal
sometimes he would allow me to console
him but most times he I would just sit
on the floor at the end of his bed and
wait for him to settle down to offer my
shoulder he just could not describe what
was bothering him I could only sit and
watch him battle with the inner
demons to say that middle school was
unpleasant for him is an understatement
relationships were difficult his
attempts at dating were forced he was
picked on on a regular basis for being
different than everybody else
at 15 he was convinced that he was gay
great I thought I finally had an answer
that he could have been worse things
like
pregnant this Revelation helped somewhat
but the pain it never helped the pain
entirely he managed to find an accepting
group of friends and had wonderful
teachers who helped him through and
somehow he managed to make it through
high school and graduate but looking
back now I see that he was never
happy as a a freshman in college he
decided to seek therapy and last year
when he told me that he had concluded
and please notice that I used the word
concluded not decided that he Associates
as male I was not really
surprised this year I have supported my
child my son in his journey as a parent
we only want our child to be
happy watching him as he transitions
into the person he was always meant to
be
has not always been
easy it's hard to understand but I never
I've never seen him happier the
transition has given him confidence that
he has never had he looks into the
mirror and he likes himself for the
first time ever forcing children to
conform to our Norms is not going to
help a transg transgender child
suppressing their identity does not make
it go away puberty is hard enough on a
child without the in a person fighting
with the outward person's
appearance I know I have W witnessed
this personally what we didn't know is
that we we could have
helped every parent should stop and
think about what if it happens to them I
did not just decide I wanted to mix it
up a little and have a transgender child
my child did not just decide that he
could use a good challenge and pretend
to be male so that he could get beat up
in a bathroom
all the signs were there from early
childhood and we had been in if we had
been better informed if we had been
educated if we had known that we could
simply and safely put off puberty and
perhaps spare him the pain depression
anger and thoughts of taking his life
the confusion he was
experiencing when while his outward
appearance was battling fiercely with
person um
hold on I lost it not to mention the
expense of the reconstructive surgery
that he finally to finally look like the
person on the outside that he hit he's
been all along on the inside which is
not all covered by medical insurance I
might add there is no doubt we would
have sent him to th therapy and put him
on puberty blockers by Middle School
please vote no to this horrible
legislation thank
you thank you so much for your testimony
did you did you say you had written
testimony I have written it down I did
not send it I can send it to you okay
that would be really helpful if you
questions okay seeing none thank you
you up next is Chris urel I hope I said
that right if not I apologize um please
State who you are where you're from and
who you're representing and whether or
not you have written testimony and
please keep in mind you have five
minutes hi um thank you so much uh
chairperson rice and members of the
committee uh my name is Chris urel and
I'm a New Hampshire licensed attorney
and I work for glbtq legal Advocates and
Defenders glad uh we're based in Boston
but we are the go-to legal services
provider for um lgbtq rights issues
across New England uh I did submit
written testimony and I believe you all
have it and I am going to take to heart
uh the message that you don't want me to
repeat things that other people have
already covered and so yeah you've
already heard from medical professionals
talking about the medically necessary
care that transgender young people need
um you've heard about what gender
dysphoria is you've heard about the
lived experience of transgender youth in
New Hampshire
um so I am going to skip right ahead to
focusing on um the law and uh
specifically the development of
non-discrimination law in New Hampshire
I I know you all are well aware that in
2018 HB
1319 um changed the landscape of
transgender rights in New Hampshire and
finally after many years of of effort by
Advocates and um activists
uh this body and was instrumental in um
in passing HB 1319 and ensured
non-discrimination protection for all
transgender people in all areas of
public life in New Hampshire and then um
beyond that uh the following year in
2019 um a new statute was passed went
into effect that uh protected young
people in schools and um you know based
on uh gender ident based on sexual
orientation based on sex religion race
all of the all of the prot protected
classifications that protect people from
discrimination and other aspects of
public life so after all of that effort
um there's there was still more work to
do and there's still is more work to do
and um and I want to highlight a couple
of other important advancements in terms
of the lived experience of transgender
people in New Hampshire one important um
bill that was passed ensured protection
for transgender people when it comes to
accessing
healthare and in fact um just last year
the division of insurance issued a
bulletin further and further um further
uh explaining why those protections are
necessary and how they operate to ensure
that transgender people are entitled to
be free from discrimination in accessing
Medical Care and so I'm highlighting
that because uh it's in direct
contradiction to what this bill proposes
to do
uh you can't on one hand uh say that
transgender people in New Hampshire
should be free from discrimination and
accessing healthare and then on the
other hand say that granting uh the
right to access health care is child
abuse um and then another important
piece of legislation that passed a
couple years ago uh that became law in
New Hampshire is the bill that uh
prohibited conversion therapy um conver
so the bill that prohibited conversion
therapy made it unlawful to try to force
a person to uh conform to their natal
sex instead of uh living in their true
gender identity that that that law was a
groundbreaking and important move
forward in New Hampshire and I just want
to clarify that that is that is
completely at odds with what this bill
is trying to do hp68 is trying to force
young people to live in their natal sex
and not live consistent with their
gender identity and uh it sends the
opposite message of what uh of what of
what all of the legislative progress
that we've made over the years is and um
I do want to emphasize that uh that that
young people in New Hampshire are
entitled to the support of um not just
the communities that surround them every
day but though but but every every um
sorry the legislation and every other
body that that represents the state just
like everyone else they're entitled to
live free from this kind of um attack on
their on their on their um on their
well-being and U I'm happy to take any
questions thank you so much are there
any
questions seeing none than oh I'm sorry
hold on representative long has a
question thank thank you madam chair
just just just a Clarity on uh uh so the
House Bill 1319 was that 2020 that's
that you suggest is in conflict with
this one no no HB 1319 passed in 2018
and went in effect into effect I believe
on January 1st of 2019 okay that's great
thank you you're
questions seeing none thank you so much
for that testimony that was helpful
up next is Kelly
Moore please um State who you are where
you're from and who you are representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and please remember to keep it
to five
minutes hi my name is Kelly Moore I'd
like to thank you for um taking the time
to listen to me today um I put in
written testimony when um it was
scheduled prior this bill um and then it
was pushed forward so I can resubmit
that
I'm running uh representing myself um so
I'm a mom of a 14-year-old boy um his
name is Devin and uh he's really good in
school he likes to play golf and he's a
really great tennis player he uh goes
snowboarding on the weekends and he's
really close with his cousins and his
family um we're hoping he gets in a
Dairy Field next
year and and um he's just like an
all-around great
kind very
kind non-judgmental kid and he also
happens to be
transgender um that's just a part of him
it does not define who he is
um we kind of knew when he was very
young that he was a tom boy is what we
thought um cuz I was not educated
about being transgender and I think that
that's a common issue in today's society
as people just need to be educated about
this that it's not something scary or
crazy um it's just it just is um it's a
a medical situation where my son was
born with female body parts um you know
he wore baseball hats he played football
he um he was just a tomboy and um he
went into counseling because he started
having some just you know emotional
struggles when he was eight I mean we
were in third grade that's young for
young for a kid and um he told me he
wanted I mean so he had put on his
Christmas list to Santa that he wanted
to be a boy and he prayed to God to be a
boy so that should have been like you
know glaring signs at that time um but I
still was not
sure when we were seeing a therapist
um they suggested that I let him explore
this um and so I did I let him get his
haircut and he started going by male
pronouns um the school he was in at the
time would not work with us um he had a
very feminine name when he was born and
they would not use his uh his male name
so I went to court and I changed his
name which was a relatively easy process
um and something that I knew that I
could change back if this was just a
phase
um I do research for work so I did a lot
of research on this topic um and of
course this was my child this is my life
is my son he's my life and um I just
want him to be happy and healthy um so
we started seeing an
endocrinologist and um kept seeing uh a
therapist and the next step was really
um puberty blockers um and I was you
know I needed to do a lot of research on
that because that's medical um but
puberty blockers are completely
reversible so even if he took those till
he was 13 and then it was just a phase
he could go off of them and go through
puberty as a
girl um so that gave a good amount of
time uh for him and I to really know
that this was something real that he
wanted
um this was not an easy time for him he
didn't choose this path he um he got
teased we I pulled him out of school
like just one day he just never went
back because of the way he was treated
by teachers and and kids which just so
wrong it's just not it's like not okay
oh sorry one minute
so anyway he has transitioned he is 14
he knows he's a boy he's not having any
kind of um surgeries or anything like
that he's happy he's healthy he is a
good member of society he's kind to
people he's non
judal um and if I if he didn't
transition I don't think I'd have a
child so you know I think
that this bill is
this bill shocks me but um you know I
strongly oppose this bill because I
think I'm a good mother raising an
incredible child and the being
transgender is is just a thing it's
trans you're being you're a
transgender so thank you for your
thank you um chairman rice chairwoman
rice for taking my question and thank
you Kelly for coming to speak with us
about share your story um I'm just
curious are there supports and services
are there parent groups in the state
like what supports are there for parents
right now um because I'm a parent of a
child that has a disability and I know
that support groups have been critical
so I'm just curious if in New Hampshire
we have that right so when he
transitioned at 8 or 9ine that's
actually very early um especially for uh
these days you know people have just
started learning what being transgender
is about and it's become more public um
there were very few we were kind of a
nationwide connection um of of people
that got together
um like a few times a year there's a
camp or two camps uh now I have found so
my son went still which means that he
didn't let anyone in his life know that
he was transgender because he felt it
was dangerous and he didn't want to get
bullied um so he he is private um so we
did not go to support groups for a while
PR
preco the a lot of support groups popped
up you know a lot of support groups his
age group um
teenagers um and they're they're kind of
all encompassing with the lgbtq
community um there's events there's
online events there's uh it's really
nice to see so much more
support so it is
available great thank you thanks for
sharing
questions seeing none thank you so much
thank
you up next is um Abby or Abby
Maxwell please State who you are where
you're from and who you're representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and you have five
minutes hello thank you for hearing my
testimony and opposition to
hp68 my name is Abby Maxwell I'm from
conquer and I did not yet sit submit my
testimony and
writing I am the parent of an 8-year-old
girl recently she filled out a
Valentine's worksheet for school and in
it I learned that she loves that she can
go in the woods from her backyard swim
and play video games that she loves that
she is brave happy and nice and that she
loves that she has pets Woods in her
backyard and lots of friends
I believe that is a good snapshot of my
daughter whose Medical Care and parents
this bill attempts to
criminalize that's because my daughter
also happens to be transgender which in
her case means she was assigned male at
Birth but is female she first began to
tell us of her gender when she was three
years old my husband and I did not know
what to make of
it and frankly we suppressed Ed as much
as possible yet as the years went on she
became increasingly insistent and when
she was six she told us that she did not
want to exist anymore if she had to
continue to be a boy we sought medical
advice and eventually we were referred
to the Boston Children's
Hospital there we learned about what it
means to be
transgender and the best practices of
gender affirming care to help my
daughter have a happy healthy life
finally after multiple appointments and
lots of research we allowed her to
change her name and pronoun and to dress
and live as the girl she'd spent years
telling us she was the change was
remarkable it was like a light came on
inside of her
overnight all who knew her noticed the
shift
instantly I know know what harms my
daughter it is that she lives in a
culture in which she came home from
second grade to tell me that she
understood that most people in the world
hate transgender people like her it is
that her parents have to spend so much
time and energy fighting for her right
to exist it is bills like this which not
only threaten her actual life but also
the health of our
communities already we have moved from
the small New Hampshire town where my
family has been for Generations because
of the Discrimination bullying and
harassment my daughter faced I know that
is not what we want for our state we do
not want to be a place that pushes
difference out yet this bill would tell
our trans youth that they will not be
safe here that they do not belong here
and in fact that we want them gone so
badly that we are willing to crimin aliz
their life-saving medical care that is
not the message our state should ever
send its residents that is not how we
build safe communities in which all our
children can
thrive in the past few years our
lawmakers have made great strides in
making our state more inclusive I urge
you to oppose this bill and continue the
work of building a New Hampshire that is
safe for all its children thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions
much up next is Jennifer Smith please
State who you are where you're from and
who you are representing and whether or
not you have written testimony and
Jennifer
Smith all right we'll have to come
back so we
him Sophia beond delilo oh I know I just
McCall hi hi this is Sophia can you hear
me okay yes could you please State who
you are where you're from and who you
are representing and whether or not you
have written testimony and please
remember you have five
minutes all right um thank you madam
chair and members of the committee for
taking my testimony today my name is
Sophia beond Lilo I'm 14 I live in
Manchester um I have written testimony
and I will email it to you guys after
the hearing um and I'm speaking today on
behalf of the New Hampshire High School
Democrats in opposition to
hp68 I'm a opposed this bill because if
it were enacted it would have
devastating effects on the mental and
physical well-being of thousands of New
Hampshire citizens and deny them access
to healthcare that is absolutely
necessary for their basic health there
are a number of reasons that this bill
is not viable but first and foremost is
the wording nowhere in this bill or in
the original legislation is the word
subject defined so it could be one of
two things either this is in reference
to a parent forcing their child to
transition or it is simply just a ban on
transitioning for minors I think it's
highly unlikely that this bill is
strictly intended to prevent parents
from forcing their children forcing
their children to medically transition
because we all acknowledge that that
would be ridiculous Force transition is
not happening in the state or anywhere
in this country and it would be
extremely difficult if ever
attended I think what's much more likely
is that this bill is explicitly or not
intended solely to prevent minors from
transitioning and accessing the
healthare they need so let's assume that
subject could apply to situations where
a child willingly transitions in that
scenario I would like to address several
things as I'm sure that so people will
testify today to try and convince the
committee that transitioning is
dangerous when it is not firstly some
people claim that people who transition
are motivated by mental illness they may
sayate that transgender people are more
at risk for certain conditions however
this insinuates a relationship between
being trans and having mental illness
that does not exist a more accurate way
to represent the statistic would be that
people who are trans are more likely to
be harassed and traumatized due to their
identity in addition there is a
condition called gender dysphoria that
many transgender people have which is
defined by the American Psychiatric
association as psychological distress
that results from an in congruence
between one's sex assigned to birth and
one's gender identity this experience
can be crippling for many gender people
and can contribute to other aspects of
their mental health but it is also the
reason why transitioning is so important
for people with gender dysphoria
according to a study from 2018 people
who have gender dysphoria are at higher
risk for suicidal ideation and other
mental health issues as we've heard
transitioning is one of the only ways
this type of dysphoria can be treated
and Leed so not only is being
transgender not a result of Mental
Illness but in fact transitioning
significantly improves mental health for
Trans people with gender
dysphoria some also say that transgender
people may regret transitioning however
that data is largely outdated in a study
in 2005 that sampled 325 people only two
expressed any regrets after
transitioning this is a minute
percentage and in no way represents any
significant amount of people especially
when you consider that almost 5,000
transgender people are estimated to live
in New Hampshire the researchers also
stated that after treatment the group
was no longer gender dysphoric and that
the vast majority functioned quite well
psychologically and socially D
transitioning is not a major issue in
New Hampshire's communities or anywhere
else and trying to use that to justify
dangerous and hateful bill is not only
wrong but also wholly lacking in any
real logical basis in conclusion what is
important to recognize is that
transitioning as a transgender person is
not a result of mental illness or a
trend or a phase but it is something
that is necessary for many transgender
people and those who experience gender
dysphoria preventing transgender people
from accessing the help they need
directly harms them and if this bill
were to be abused it would have exactly
that effect so in conclusion I urge the
committee to do what is necessary to
project transgender people in the State
questions seeing none thank you very
testimony so so up next is Amy
manzelli please State who you are where
you're from and who you are representing
and whether or not you have submitted
written testimony and please remember
you have five
minutes thank you good afternoon
honorable Vice chair D Simone can you
hear
me yes thank you uh my name is Amy
maneli I'm from 418 Ross Road in
Pembrook New Hampshire I'm submitted my
my and my husband's letter dated
February 3rd uh over email so hopefully
you have that in your record I'm here
today with my husband Chad trell and
with our 11-year-old transgender
daughter Iris hi we'd like to request
respectfully that you vote itl on House
Bill
68 we wanted to share with you a bit of
our daughter's story and you'll hear
some commonalities from The Other
Stories you've heard
while Iris was assigned male gender at
Birth it is clear to us now that our
daughter has always been a girl
beginning at age three every year she
said she wanted Santa Claus to turn her
into a
girl eventually when she was six she
wanted her outward identity to match her
inner
identity and I went into the details in
my letter of how she expressed that to
us and very child appropriate ways she
needed to wear only girls clothes she
needed to use the female pronoun she
needed a girl's
name in a matter of a few months her
coming out was complete including our
family having established a wonderful
relationship with the great team at
Boston Children's Hospital our daughter
sees an entire team of health
professionals there who collaborate with
similar experts worldwide including a
medical doctor a nurse practitioner and
a psychologist our daughter's capable
team adhere to the gold standard in
medical treatment of gender diverse
patients that is to perform a
Comprehensive Psychological and medical
assessment to create an
individualized treatment
plan our daughter's providers know that
untreated gender dysphoria would put her
at much greater risk of suicide and
other grave emotional challenges hp68
would put us as parents in a position of
becoming criminals under New Hampshire
law if we follow that individualized
treatment plan created by our daughter's
medical team it would put our daughter
at risk of grave harm other children's
families have the personal freedom to
decide what medical treatment is
appropriate for their children our
family would have that taken away from
us if h68 became
law it's been almost 4 years since Iris
came out and her identifying as a girl
remains consistent and persistent she's
gone through the legal processes to
change her gender marker to female and
to change her name to a traditional name
for a girl Iris being a girl is like the
color of her skin or the height she will
be when she grows up it is an
inescapable and inherent
characteristic we are so proud to live
in the granite state where our
daughter's rights as a transgender girl
have been recognized and
protected please do not erode this
progress our daughter has the same
rights as any other girl as a licensed
attorney I know that the legal Community
agrees with this the medical community
agrees I hope this esteemed committee
will also agree by itm
h68 and Iris would like to say a brief
word to the
committee hi my name is Iris trell um
please don't make my parents criminals
for giving me the medical treatment that
I need please vote no
thanks thank you members of the
committee we would welcome any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you up next is um Jeanie
husa um please State who you are where
you're from and who you're representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and please remember you have
five minutes thank you madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Jeanie hesa I'm from conquered and I'm
sorry I'm sorry Miss Hera can you hold
on one minute please I'm sorry
representative
Marsh I'll take care of this I am very
sorry for the interruption
representative harus I mean represent
genusa please continue no worries um so
I'm I'm the political director and we'll
be representing U the American civil
liberties Union of New Hampshire I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
today in opposition to HB 68 um there's
been some incredible testimony given
already and so I'm going to focus uh my
oral testimony on our legal concerns
with this bill and I've submitted longer
written testimony to the committee I
want to underscore that passage of this
bill would result in New Hampshire
falling out of compliance with state and
federal law which could open the state
to legal action by those families
prevented from accessing medically NE
necessary care federal courts have held
that discrimination against transgender
individuals is impermissible sex
discrimination under the US Constitution
and federal laws prohibiting
discrimination on the basis of sex this
includes title 7 and section 1557 of the
Affordable Care Act moreover
discrimination against transgender
individuals is also impermissible sex
discrimination under our comparable
anti-discrimination state laws where law
singles out People based on the fact
that they have a gender identity that
does not match the sex assigned to them
at Birth it necessarily discriminates on
the basis of sex and trans status as the
US Supreme Court stated just last year
quote it is impossible to discriminate
against a person for being transgender
without discriminating against that
individual based on sex for example a
bill that permits medical treatment for
example hormone ther therapy when
medically necessary for a
non-transgender minor but that would
criminalize parents for supporting the
same procedure for a transgender minor
for whom it is also medically necessary
treatment for gender dysphoria
discriminates based on sex gender
identity transgender status and sex
stereotyping put simply this bill would
result in discrimination it would deny
families the ability to care for
transgender minors and ultimately lead
to devastating Health outcomes for
vulnerable young people the bill has no
sound basis in science or medicine and
would open the state of New Hampshire to
costly and protracted legal challenges
for these reasons I respectfully urge
the members of this committee to vote
itl on HB 68 and I'd be happy to answer
questions thank you very much are there
any
questions seeing none thank you very
you up next is Amber
Lor please State who you are where
you're from and who you are representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and please remember you have
five
minutes good afternoon members of the
children and family law committee my
name is ambera tour and I live in
Guilford New Hampshire I'm here as a
private citizen representing myself I
have sent in testimony I'm here to
oppose h b68 relative to the definition
of child abuse I've thought the previous
testimony has been very powerful
especially from the parents of trans
children um I have a little bit of a
different perspective as I am a mom of
an eight-year old cisgender um
daughter um if but at any point she
shows that she identifies those trans as
a trans child it would be a long process
with many healthc care providers
involved gender affirming treatments are
not taken lightly and they're under the
care of a trained doctor I have concerns
with this bill as any parent should
because it inserts the government into
the role of parents and doctors and
prohibits them from making informed
decisions for the children's whose care
is entrusted to
them we've heard study after study has
shown that affirming trans kids and
following the affirming model has been
recommended by nearly every Major
Medical
Association on a personal level I have
witnessed one of my daughters friends
come out as
trans and I've seen how much affirming
her gender has impacted her behavior in
a positive way she is much happier she
smiles more and it's so easy to see her
confidence has
improved it's like she is a different
child
she has caring and loving parents and
this is not
abuse for a parent of a trans kid this
bill can do harm to a child's future and
can contribute to more
suicides but all of us parents should be
concerned about a bill like this Medical
Treatments should be Private Matter
between children their parents and
trained
doctors I urge you to oppose this bill
and keep the government government out
of our doctor's offices I want to thank
you to the committee for allowing me to
express my concerns about this Bill
thank you thank you so much are there
any
again up next is Kim Peasley please
State who you are where you're from and
who you are representing and whether or
not you have written testimony and
remember you have five
minutes good afternoon this is Kim
Peasley I am from Conquer New Hampshire
I'm an attorney in the area I work and
live here I am representing myself and
my transgender son I did submit written
testimony on the thir if you need me to
resubmit it I'm happy to do so I won't
need five minutes and I appreciate
everyone who spoken before me but just
wanted to add um my two cents Madam
chairman and the rest of the committee
thank you so much for your time today
I'm testifying today in opposition to
hp68 introduced by representative Dave
testerman of marac his bill as we all
know seeks to add sexual harassment to
the sexual reassignment to the
definition of an abused child as a
legislator in New Hampshire one must
take an oath which states in part I will
faithfully and impartially discharge and
perform all my D all the duties
incumbent on me as a state
representative according to the best of
my abilities it is also to be understood
that prior to proposing any law to
abridge citizens rights a modum of
research on the relevant subject matter
should be a requirement a brief Google
search provided me with the following
that as far back as 2019 the American
Medical Association approximated about
150,000 youth ages 13 to 17 in the US
identify as transgender that meaning
those individuals whose gender identity
and or expression is different from
cultural expectations based on the sex
they were assigned at Birth the AMA
notes that every Major Medical
Association in the US recognizes the
medical necessity of transition related
care from improving the physical and
mental health of transgender people
where medically necessary services that
affirm gender or treat gender dysphoria
may include but are not limited to
mental health counseling non-medical
social transition gender affirming
hormone therapy and or gender affirming
surgeries furthermore the AMA has found
that gender-based discriminating
affecting access to Services Bill
suggests
that such as hp68 is a strong predictor
of suicide risk among transgender
persons here are teens the AMA cited
studies which show that suicide rates
dropped from 30% pre-treatment to 8%
post treatment hp68 runs counter to the
state's most precious tenant to live
free I for one take these Liberties very
seriously hp68 seeks to marginalize a
subset of our children and criminalize
their medically necessary Health Care to
interfere with our children and their
doctors to interfere with parents care
for their children is clearly an
interference on our children's life
liberty and privacy just to name a few
on its face this bill is born not only
out of ignorance but is a blatant
attempt to dehumanize a group of
individuals deemed different or less
than by the Bill's sponsor transmen are
men trans women are women they are
citizens of our country and of our state
and just like me we all deserve
protection under the Constitution New
Hampshire children should be able to
live free and not die due to withholding
of medically necessary treatment by the
New Hampshire legislature I also believe
strongly that accountability is needed
for those who seek to dehumanize any
group whether through their use of
language or their actions my position is
that hp68 is repugnant to the rights and
Liberties contained in the New Hampshire
state constitution and must be deemed
inexpedient to legislate thank you for
your
questions seeing none thanks again thank
you up next is Matthew cron please State
who you are where you're from and who
you are representing and whether or not
you have written testimony and please
remember you have five
minutes uh my name is Matthew cron I'm
from Auburn New Hampshire uh I'm just
representing myself I have emails in
written testimony um most of what I have
to say has already been said uh I just
felt it necessary to speak out on behalf
of every parent and child who may have
to work through such a potentially
difficult
process um as a parent my job is to
support trust and love my child and this
bill directly interferes with that
relationship by making it a Crim
criminal act to help your child receive
gender affirmative care um
you know you've already heard that the
American Academy of P Pediatrics
condemns bills like these um about the
long-term psychological and physical uh
and emotional harm that can be caused by
denying these gender affirmative
therapies to Children um you know the
best way to help these these transgender
children is to ensure that it continues
to be legal to provide them with medical
care and to trust them when they tell us
who they really are uh this bill only
serves to harm a group that is already
at risk and should not be passed thank
you thank you very much are there any
again up next is
Rowan quian I know I butchered that name
I'm so sorry um please State who you are
where you're from and who you're
representing and whether or not you have
written testimony and you have five
minutes thank you so my name is Rowan
quam you actually got the pronunciation
right um uh I'm from Manchester New
Hampshire uh representing myself I have
not sent in written testimony but I have
written down my remarks and I can send
them to you uh later
today we have already heard that hp68 is
is not based in the latest Medical
Science we have already heard that it
would deny life-saving care to an
incredibly vulner vulnerable population
and contradict existing law and we have
heard very moving testimony from parents
of transgender children as well as a
transgender child I worry that the
motivation for this bill since it is not
based in science or pre-existing law is
instead based in the belief that it is
bad or wrong to be transgender so what I
want to offer you briefly is direct
testimony from a transgender person
I am a gay transgender man I grew up in
rural Iowa in the late 90s and 2000s and
I did not even know what it meant to be
a transgender until I was in college now
that I have transitioned I can say
confidently that the choice to do so was
the best decision I have ever made it
has opened up my life in ways that I
never could have imagined when I was a
child I don't even know how to express
this to folks who haven't lived through
something like it when I look in the
mirror and see my my face when I talk to
people and hear the way that my voice
sounds when I look at my body and see
how much it has changed because of the
health care that I have been able to
access I am grateful every single day
beyond words the fact that young
transgender people are now able to
access quality gender affirming Health
Care at a younger age than I did is
amazing and wonderful and should be
celebrated not stifled because it is a
good thing to be trans I am so proud to
be
trans this bill is unscientific
Prejudiced and cruel and I urge you to
vote no I'm happy to take any questions
questions seeing none thanks so much and
I'm glad I didn't kill your name thank
you up next is Lisa pantelli
please state do we have
White okay so please State Jordan who
you are where you're from and who you
are representing and whether or not you
have written testimony and please
remember you have five minutes thank you
so much uh my name is Jordan Applewhite
I live in Sugar Hill and representing
myself I did not yet submit written
testimony to the committee um I'm here
to speak in a opposition to hp68 a bill
which effectively criminalizes the
existence of transgender children I am a
transgender resident in New Hampshire
trans people including trans children
want to live their lives with the same
dignity and respect that is afforded to
all other citizens not to be styed by
bigotry and used as divisive political
prop
I came out just before my 30th birthday
transitioning that late in my life was
extremely difficult and disruptive I
know young people who are discovering
themselves at a much earlier age and it
fills my heart with love and joy that
they will not face the same difficulties
I faced it is my duty as an LGBT Elder
to make sure they don't when trans youth
receive medical treatment it's typically
to delay the onset of puberty until they
decide they want horse hormone
replacement therapy or HRT HR RT allows
them to experience gender affirming
physical development as they grow into
adulthood rather than feeling like a
stranger in their own body a condition
called disphoria which leads many to
depression and
suicide transmed care saves lives
puberty blockers are safe HRT is safe so
let me be clear anyone supporting HB 68
should be ashamed of themselves this
bill does not have the safety of trans
children at heart in fact the langage of
the bill displays an obsession with
regulating children's genitals anyone
who thinks this is okay should seek
counseling for this unhealthy fixation
it does not belong in our state
legislature let trans children live
their lives in peace now I volunteer at
my local church I'm married I own
property pay taxes here I run a small
business and employs a dozen people
there are countless trans people just
like me living among you and if this
bill is Advanced we and our allies will
remember who is responsible for that and
we will mobilize against them thank you
for your time and thank you so much to
the parents of trans children who showed
up here
today thank you for your testimony are
there any
you okay so up next will be Nancy
Brennan please State who you are where
you're from and who you are representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and you have five minutes good
afternoon I did send testimony along
with a couple of articles for you to
look at my name is Nancy Brennan I'm an
old ciswoman from where I speak in
opposition to
hp68 like some of you on this panel and
like the bills sponsor himself when we
were six or 16 or 26 even
we didn't know or we didn't know we knew
any transgender people we may have read
Life magazine and and heard about
Christine Jorgenson the first famous
transgender person a World War II vet
who transitioned in the early
1950s but we were mostly ignorant about
what it meant to be transgender I dare
say that unless we are transgender
ourselves or ra in a transgender child
or we are a medical worker treating um a
transgender person or researching what
it means to be transgender we still
don't really know but we can listen to
our friends who are living this
experience we can read comprehensive
evidence-based research and we can
hopefully separate fact from fake
information representative testerman
said helping transgender children and be
their authentic selves just makes no
sense I would ask him to do some
in-depth research talk to parents health
care workers and the many courageous
young people who have given testimony on
this bill and all of those who spoke in
favor of passing the transgender
non-discrimination Bill a couple of
years ago I would ask that he listen to
the testimony he missed last week and
maybe today as well we have come a long
way in 70 years we now know that gender
identity is a complex combination of
brain function Gene variance hormone
levels and Myriad other factors and that
most transgender children are aware of
their gender at a very young age helping
these children live as their authentic
selves makes them much happier much more
St able and even saves their lives
treating transgender children is not
child abuse one expert has said that
denying proper care to transgender
children is akin to denying care for
asthma or cancer these are decisions to
be made for the families of the child
the child themselves their doctors and
medical team not to be made made by
legislators I urge you to vote itl on
this Bill thank
questions seeing none thank
you up next is Julian
Davis please State who you are where
you're from and who you are representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and you have five minutes sure
my name is Julian Davis I'm a resident
of Guilford New Hampshire um I sent in
written testimony just a few hours ago
and I'll be representing myself today um
so I have many concerns about this bill
like everybody else who has come to
speak today thankfully most of the
people who have come to speak were able
to uh clarify some misconceptions about
transitioning during childhood as well
as some of the legal issues around this
bill so I won't waste my time by
reiterating those details instead I want
to talk about what it's like to live as
a trans Youth Without access to medical
care that we have gathered to discuss
today um so some of you may have
connected the dots my mom came on
earlier to speak about my experience but
I think it's important to sort of hear
about uh how it is to live as a trans
person directly from trans people as
well um so I'm a trans person of course
and I came to that conclusion as a young
adult but I often think about what life
could have been like if I had access to
blockers and HRT at a younger age it was
incredibly uplifting to hear the testim
Tony of trans youth who have had the
opportunity to express themselves before
adulthood but for me there is a
bitterness to these sweet stories of
self-discovery I find myself mourning
the boy I never got to be in thinking of
the 20 years worth of photos and home
videos that my family and friends have
that I can't cherish because the person
in those photos is not me I think about
all the times I posed for one of these
pictures or tried on an outfit at a
clothing store expecting to see myself
as the person I felt I was only to
become overcome with shock
disappointment and Dread upon looking at
the photo or gazing in the mirror I
remembered all the times I listened for
the call of my dead name during
attendance and class in cringed at the
fact that I knew I would have to say
here in response and yes like many
people who identify as trans I am
forever marked by the painful memories
and thoughts uh of thoughts and attempts
at
suicide the truth of the matter is when
I was growing up I existed in a visce
grip of standards and expectations that
I could never meet from the day that I
was born until the day I realized why I
felt so out of place so removed from the
present at all times I was imprisoned
both by my physical body and the set of
roles and characteristics arbitrarily
assigned to me by a doctor who took one
look at my infantile body and said it's
a girl I'm grateful to come as far as I
have under those severe circumstances
and I can finally say that the person I
am out here matches the me I am in my
head but I can't get those 20 years of
memories back and it pains me to think
that our St State Legislature might take
from the trans youth of today two whole
Decades of their lives as well of course
representative testman having never
experienced dor himself ored a
transgender child has no understanding
of what this is like I don't fault him
for that I do however fault him for
being purposefully obstinate in the face
of countless statistical figures and
data points surrounding this topic and
for being unwilling to listen to the
accounts of those of us who do have a
personal stake in this game this man
quite literally left the first hearing
just prior to the response Forum which
raises a question my mind and I'm sure
in the minds of many of those of us who
testified as well why did representative
testerman leave during the hearing
perhaps he knew his ideas would not hold
steadfast in the face of opposition or
perhaps he did not want to hear a slew
of personal anecdotes about the lives of
various trans team and parents of trans
children whom I would like to add he is
supposed to represent as an official of
the New Hampshire House of
Representatives either way the message
that I and my fellow citizens of the
State of New Hampshire seek to convey
app lies representative testerman not
only are your assertions on the matter
faulty their implications are dangerous
I urge you all to vote against House
Bill 68 thank
questions seeing none thank you very
much up next is m Michelle St
John um please State who you are where
you're from and who you're representing
and whether or not you have written
testimony and you have five
minutes thank you madam chair and
members of the committee uh my name is
Michelle St John I reside in Hollis New
Hampshire and I'm representing myself
and
Myer and my transgender child thank you
for the opportunity to provide testimony
today I'm here as a parent a New
Hampshire resident and a former state
representative and I'm voicing my
unequivocal opposition of
hp68 I'm really not sure how many
members of the committee have close
personal relationships with any
transgender youth but I do I I have
personal relationships with many I don't
know how many committee members know
what it means to identify as a
transgender as it is one of if not the
most misunderstood and discriminated
population in the world today imagine
waking up every day and realizing you're
living in a body that has nothing to do
with how you think you and who you are
there are children in New Hampshire
across our nation and throughout the
world who do every day being
transgender is never an intentional
Choice children look to their parents
relatives and other adults in their life
for gender affirming support it is not
child abuse for a parents to seek out
and explore the gender affirming medical
standard care available for transgender
youth it's a process that includes many
medical and mental health evaluations
prior to the onset of
care denying your child the opportunity
to hit the pause button prior to the
onset of adolescence Menses or other
bodily changes that occur in puberty can
cause further distress anxiety
depression self harm and even attempted
suicide human Rights Campaign the
transgender equality Foundation the
American Academy of Pediatrics and the
endrin society all provide excellent
background on what it means to be
transgender provide familial support and
medical recommendations and guidelines
for transgender children and gender
affirming care if ped this bill would
essentially constitute parents as child
abusers if they seek out the medical
support
necessary for gender affirmation care I
just ask that the committee let that
sink in for a moment loving parents
supporting their child's well-being
accused of child abuse we are all human
beings this type of legislation is
discrimination and I'd like to add that
representative testerman brought this
bill before the committee last
session in to this situation today and
the one before he was was the sole
sponsor of the
bill and in his introduction on February
3rd he self- admitted he has no
interactions with any transgender
children or
adults his only expertise in leading to
this bill is that he's a parent and a
background and with that I'd like to
close and say please vote itl on this
bill and I appreciate your time thank
you thank you very much good to hear
from you are there um any questions for
much okay that concludes our
testimony and so I will
um wait somebody just raised their hand
M please State who you are where you're
from and who you are representing and
whether or not you have written
testimony and you have five
minutes awesome thank you so much you
guys can hear me yes thank you awesome
so I'm Jenny Manelli I'm from penberg
New Hampshire I'm uh representing myself
and a family relative I emailed written
testimony dated on February 3rd I'm
wholeheartedly strongly opposing
hp68 I'm you guys have heard it all I'm
so thrilled to hear that there are so
many individuals opposing this house
bill um I applaud and thank all those
trans attendees today who spoke up I
loved what Nancy Brennan said I just I'm
I'm not going to my letter verbatim but
I'm just baffled at how people like
representative Dave testerman
can um I I just don't understand how
they could live with themselves knowing
that if if this bill were to be approved
you'd be putting the lives of
transgenders on the line I it baffles me
um makes my blood boil to think that
people would mess with my relative like
this and all the other lives of
transgenders out there I
just get it it doesn't make sense
um you guys have heard everything but my
the parents of my
relatives of my relative and my trans
relative they're not criminals they
should not be criminals they have done
nothing but love their transgender
daughter for who she is and and how she
is they they're get they're doing all
the right things they're getting the
medical advice that that this relative
of mine needs
um we are in the Live Free or Die I love
how someone else said that this this
shouldn't be live free you know or
literally die um I'm thrilled and proud
that my relatives rights thus far have
been recognized and protected but again
this house bill it would put an end to
the progress that has been made thus
far and I just can't imagine the
negative impact and the grave Danger
that would result from
this house bill being passed um please
do not stop their progress this the
there are wonderfully medically trained
professionals that are overseeing the
lives of these transgender
use um it's with my deepest hopes that
this esteemed committee will agree by
voting to inexpedient to legislate this
house bill 68 thank you so much thank
you are there any
questions seeing none thank you very
much our last person to testify today is
Aaron Brewer please um State who you are
where you're from and who you are
representing and whether or not you have
written testimony and remember you have
five
minutes thank you my name is Aaron
Brewer and I did submit written
testimony I'm from Logan Utah and I
represent myself and I know we've heard
a few stories from um people who are
very against this bill but I am here in
support of it and it's because I was a
trans kid I was so insistent and
persistent and consistent in my demands
that I was a boy that my teacher sent me
to the school psychologist to be
evaluated the school psychologist
admitted that yes indeed I wanted to be
a boy but thankfully she did not affirm
me instead she came up with a plan to
help me manage my feelings of distress
and resolve those dysphoric feelings it
took a while but eventually I did learn
to feel comfortable with myself and I'm
so
grateful that she did not affirm me
because if she had I never would have
had the opportunity to explore the fact
that those gender dysphoric feelings
that trans identity was the direct
result of a sexual assault that occurred
when I was assaulted I decided I was not
going to be a girl anymore I hated the
body that I believe believed had been
assaulted and wanted to distance myself
from it I absolutely did not want to be
a girl anymore and I'm not the only one
I've talked to many many D transitioners
who've had the same story they felt that
their body had betrayed them and they
wanted to run away from it if we
encourage children to transition we
basically discourage them from we if we
we discourage them from getting the help
that they need to understand those
feelings of of self-hatred and shame
that are so common with such sexual
assaults she did not affirm the
self-hatred that I had she did not put
me on puberty blockers that would have
induced a developmental delay instead
she put me in a communication group and
she got me support which is what I
really
needed it breaks my heart to imagine
what my life would have been like if my
school psychologist told me that I was
inherently flawed and that the only way
to fix myself was to damage my healthy
body with puberty blockers cross- sex
hormones and
surgery doing so would have prevented me
from getting the help that I needed to
understand the trauma that I endured it
would have convinced me that my
dissociating from my body was
appropriate and the only way to manage
the feelings I had of
distress and it would have prevented me
from having the three beautiful children
that I have today that have brought me
so much
joy and is heartbreaking to me that
vulnerable children with history of
trauma like mine children who are
autistic children who have internalized
homophobia children who are acting in
ways that are not supported by today's
social standards of
stereotypes are being subjected to
experimental interventions that damage
their healthy bodies especially when we
know that the vast majority of them will
resolve their feelings of dysphoria if
they are allowed to progress naturally
through
puberty these children who deserve our
love and our compassion they need skills
to manage their difficult feelings but
they also deserve our protection they
need to hear the message loud and clear
no child is born in the wrong body thank
you very much for hearing my
testimony thank you very much are there
any
so people are starting to raise their
hands now we are going to take a
15minute break because we've been at
this for a while we need to get up and
walk around I see two hands up those are
the two that I will recognize when we
get back and then we are
done okay we had plenty of time to sign
up to testify in advance and we have
other business we have to attend to
today so we'll be back in 15 minutes
thank
[Music]
that
GL
e
spe
after
you
the
thank
okay if everybody can start moseying
back to their
computers we'll start up again in a
okay welcome back
everybody like I said we have two more
people to hear
from the first
is Marie
landrian please State who you are where
you're from and who you are representing
and whether or not you have written
all right we'll come back to Marie
landeron and we'll go to Annie Blanchett
please State who you are where you're
from who you are representing and
whether or not you have testimony and
you have five
minutes hi my name is an Blanchette I'm
from low Massachusetts I'm representing
myself um I did send an email I don't
know if that's the same as testimony
I've never done this before um so I'm
really nervous and Confused um I am
supporting this bill um though I live in
Massachusetts I have a grandson that
lives in New Hampshire who has been um
pushed on the path of the gender
ideology and that's what I call it
because that's what I believe it is I
believe it is not an ideology he was not
even 7 years old when my daughter and
her transgender spouse decided that he
too was also
transgender um I've known him his whole
life I've been uh participating a
grandmother his whole life all the way
up to that time I have never seen a sign
of gender dysphoria in him since the day
he was born I even cut his CT um so when
my daughter came out and said that he
was transgender I said you know I didn't
know much about it even though I knew
the spouse was transgender but it was
the decision that she made when she was
an adult um I went along with it I
supported it I supported it when my
daughter and this woman got married and
after the transition it was when they
decided to transition a seven-year-old
boy I did some research and uh my
daughter was very excited at the
prospect of him going on puberty
blockers when he was nine and I'm like
he's not even seven yet and you're
talking about puberty blockers what a
puberty blockers I started to do
research on him and the harms they are
they are not
reversible like activists and people
want to tell you I have researching this
for four years um because I would not go
along with the ideology I have been cut
out of his life I have not seen him in
four years um this whole thing destroys
families um tears in the pot but be
besides that just the medical aspect of
what these drugs do the thing is is the
W path and AAP all say these little
children that have gender dysphoria and
need to persistance stuff they're
insistent consistent persistent all the
way from the time they're three all the
way up my grandson was not that then you
got all these teenagers that are on
social media Tumblr um all of sudden
waking up at 61516 saying they're
transgender and there are over 60s
something gender clinics in the United
States and many of them between them and
clean planin Hood teenagers can walk in
on the first visit and get hormones on
the first visit so a lot of these
clinics are not even following their own
protocol that they should be living the
life they should for like two years
before any kind of medication there's a
doctor California Joanna ol Kennedy who
got 55 million in an nhi study and
started testing testosterone on
eight-year-old girls because they're
finding out that the puberty blockers
are not
working you know so the they're finding
out the puberty blockers are not helping
these children because they're stunting
the children when they're ATT and
they're not keeping up with their PE so
they're pushing the testosterone younger
they're removing healthy breasts at 13
years old old of girls who are confused
that don't want to fit into a gender
stereotypical box of what it's supposed
to be to be a female or what it's
supposed to be to be a male you know
what is gender anyways and why are we
medicalizing these
children when 80 to 90% of them desist
there hi CL can you hear us I can now
but somebody muted me you hear how much
did you hear you weren't muted you just
we just lost you for a few seconds I
don't know what happened but it it
wasn't long okay how far did you
heard hello I I don't know you you were
talking about
90 healthy breasts were
removed 13year olds they removing
healthy breasts um there is you know
most of the testimony I did hear you
know that they're saying that you know
oh they wish they had that when they
were a child it's like they don't know
what they would have had happened if
they were a child and they're lucky that
they got to make these decisions for
themselves as an adult the thing is this
children cannot consent just had a case
in the UK I don't know if you heard
about the caribel case um they they it
was huge all the way up to the Supreme
Court or whatever it is called out there
and they determined that children under
16 cannot give conformed
consent now here in the United States
children cannot smoke they can't drink
they can't get tattoos there are a lot
of things that children cannot do
because they cannot give informed
consent so we are medically sterilizing
these children
and teenagers when they don't even know
what they're doing I mean every adult in
this in this in room knows what it's
like to be a teenager every woman in
this room knows what it's like to go
through puberty and how uncomfortable it
is those are just things that are part
of natural life um I my personal views I
don't believe there's anything such
thing as a trans child but I do believe
that children can have gender dysphoria
and they can be confused about you know
the stere stereotypical things that they
you know if you're a little boy and you
want to play with a bobby that does not
make you a girl you're a boy that likes
a Bobby and there's nothing wrong with
that Society needs to change what
expectations we are supposed to
have amongst ourselves instead
of thank you um instead of you
know instead of put you you're taking
these children and your medically moving
from one stereotypical box and putting
them into another when they can just be
what they want to be you know I I I
absolutely oppose this bill I mean I
support this bill
apologize um I hope you heard that
correction I absolutely support this
bill there are more and more bills like
this coming across the United States
like I said I've been researching in
finding this for the last four years
I've even gone to as far as DC to push
for the block of PU blockers this is a
medical Scandal happening across the
whole United States not just in New
Hampshire thank you for your time thank
you are there any
[Music]
questions seeing none thank you very
much Marie
landrian yes can you hear me there you
are could you please State who you are
where you're from and who you are
representing and whether you or not you
have written testimony and you have five
minutes
yes my name is Marie Lan I'm speaking on
behalf of my transgender child um I'm
from New York and we often vacation in
New Hampshire um I strongly oppose this
bill HB
68 ladies and gentlemen of the committee
I am the parent of a transgender child
oh I'm sorry yes I do have written um
testimony um this bill that has been
introduced wants to make any treatment
that would alleviate the gender
dysphoria in a transgender or nonbinary
child be illegal and counted as child
abuse this is absolutely ridiculous not
only because it would violate the rights
of every single child that does not fit
into the black and white gender binary
that the society is
currently accepting as the norm but it
would also incriminate parents who are
just trying to be supportive of their
children my son has been who was born
female was saying that they were a boy
since they were four years old this is
actually common as psychologists show
that children show Express their gender
around preschool
age um we tried a lot of things we tried
I you know I'm like a very strong
feminist I was like well maybe we just
need to empower and make sure that they
see strong representations of women
which in fact they have and were given
but that did not fix the problem the
Tinkerbell skateboards
um and all of that did not change the
fact that my son was in fact my
son
um Title Nine actually protect protects
citizens on the basis of sex and gender
but also gender identity um Title Nine
of the education Amendments of 1972 and
in
2016 um then President Obama did make it
clear that he wanted to um include
transgender people of all ages under
this legislation they stated then that a
um about schools um which said a
president a school must not treat
transgender students differently from
the way it treats other
students um also I would like to bring
up the fact that transgender and
nonbinary individuals have always
existed throughout the world and
throughout history just because in our
society or our country we have not maybe
not heard of these people or it's not in
mainstream culture does not mean that
they have not existed
in fact Medical Science have proven that
there are at least six distinct
biological Sexes and any number
Limitless gender Expressions before um
Europeans colonized the globe thousands
of indigenous people actually
acknowledged and celebrated multiple
gender identities as part of their
culture um a lot of this was erased when
they were colonized but there are many
Native people today um who do
acknowledge two spirit people and other
um definitions all over the globe um a
famous two spirit Fred Martinez for
example was not a boy who wanted to be a
girl but both a boy and a girl in ident
identity his Navajo culture recognized
and re revered as nadle he meanwhile
Hina of Kina is a part of native
Hawaiian culture that has traditionally
revered and respected mahu those who
embody both Fe male and female Spirit um
I have included in my testimony a map
for reference where you can see people
all over the World throughout history
who have existed outside of the male
female binary and some of these people
were very revered and respected by their
society um as they held important roles
in the society including being Healers
of others um I just I find it
heartbreaking that we are only seeing
these through our narrow
definition um hormone blockers or
hormone treatment can often be but is
not the only approach roate course for
transgender pre-teens and teens my child
is now 13 so we've been doing this for
N9 years and being the research nerd
that I am I have been researching this
extensively for nine years as
well
um they don't just let you get hormone
blockers they make you their child you
and your child go to therapy to many
many doctors which we have gone through
in many sessions and to make sure that
the child and yourself um and your
parenting skills are up to par they make
sure that your child is psychologically
sound and healthy they make sure that
your child is physically healthy hormone
blockers in and of themselves simply
delay puberty and are used for a variety
of reasons be besides gender identity as
well including precocious or early
puberty in girls especially whose bodies
are more easily affected by the
pesticides in our environment and in the
hormones that we eat the most important
thing is protecting transgender children
this bill is not a protection as other
people have said it is abuse posing as
protection the rate of transgender
suicide has been shown to be
significantly higher than the rates for
other
hormones I'm sorry than the rates for
other youth five times higher compared
to their heterosexual dis gender peers
however parents who support their
children's true identities can mitigate
the risk of self harm and attempted
suicide um I've quoted Dr Caitlyn Ryan
in the family acceptance project which
found that lgbtq youth whose families
affirm their gender identity and sexual
orientation are almost 50% less likely
to make a suicide attempt compared to
those whose families are
unsupported acceptance and receiving
appropriate Medical Care and enum
therapy can quite literally save the
lives of transgender and non-gender
conforming children and teens children
know who they are and they need to be
supported taking away the rights of
transgender children is abuse supporting
them is love please do not allow the
hatred and ignorance of a small group of
individuals who have no
scientific medical or
psychological um standing overall to
abuse good people children and their
parents who love
them I ask you to please vote against
this Bill thank
you thank you very much are there any
[Music]
questions okay I see none thank you very
very
much I'm now closing the public hearing
on
h68 and Madame clerk can you please get
ready because we're going to exec
ready yes one moment please Madam
chair
Madam shair I'm
ready okay representative Marsh and
representative adeler will you be
joining us because you have to have your
cameras on to vote thank you there you
are representative Mar m madam Shar I
can't start my camera oh you just gave
me the ability thank you there you go
okay all right so this is going to be
the exec exec session for
hp68 representative Banger do you have a
motion I do Madam chair I
enthusiastically move to itl
hp68 do we have a
second seconded by representative
liwicki
roll oh I'm sorry representative grman I
didn't see you go
ahead thank you uh representative rice
for taking my question chairwoman
um can we just hear how many people
signed in opposing and do we have that
number I'm gonna be honest it's not
accurate anymore because of last week I
only have like this week's I would have
to do
math okay you know what I mean like
because last week's list was I had
stated what I can I can do what today's
list was it's today's list somewhere let
me find hold on what did I just do with
my list
Madam what's that Madam chair last the
last session was uh 360
people okay so today um 27 signed in in
support and 385 signed in in opposition
position thank
you okay now any anything
role representative D
Simone
yes representative
yella
yes representative L Wiki
yes representa
representative
Banger
yes representative
Lichfield
who's representative
Smith yes sorry my husband is working
me thank you representative long
yes representative Ally say says
yes representative
grman
L
yes represent
was
yes representative
patrio
yes representative Al Schiller
yes madame chair representative
rice
yes 15 Z without objection it can go on
calendar thank you thanks so much
everybody that's a wrap for today I
think we've had a long enough
day thanks so much have a great weekend